okay rolling all right
all right hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and you know if if it's
being filmed that means that I have a
very special guest
because as some of you who aren't who
are new to the podcast I usually just
talk to myself
in my little uh man cave there but every
once in a while somebody comes to town
that I I have to sit down and talk with
and this is no this is not an exception
the one and only Mike Donovan is here he
has a new stand-up book called The
stand-up comedy book a collection of
thought stories biographies jokes and
journals of stand up Mike Donovan one of
the legends of the Boston comedy scene I
when I started out welcome to the
podcast first of all
um when I started out you were one of
the guys
that I used to watch and I would sit in
the back of the club and just watch you
get on these rolls and just absolutely
like level the room
and you would be killing so hard that I
forgot that I wanted to be a comedian or
that was trying to be a comedian I
literally you you're one of those guys
it was so funny that you became
like an audience member and I remember
sitting in the back of the club thinking
how do you get
that funny so do you think because this
is what people have always asked me why
there's so many funny guys
coming out of Boston like I always said
the guys that started
set the bar so high
and there was a standard to be original
and no stealing jokes and none of that
[__]
yeah I hear you that's right yeah oh you
got you got punched in the nose
and I just remember watching all of you
guys how hard you killed
that I didn't think that it was out of
the ordinary like when I would watch you
guys killing like my idea of what
killing is
is because of guys like you Lenny knoxy
rest his soul Tony V all of those guys
Gavin Sweeney all of them and I remember
when I moved to New York
oh God this is going to start some [__]
but I moved to New York and I saw people
coming off stage going like ah dude I
killed I [__] slayed and I would be
like I mean you had a good set yeah some
of these people that say I killed I say
you should be killed yeah
killing is and right that wasn't killing
it I got to stand I killed last night I
I've known you 20 years I've never seen
you kill apparently it's only when I
never see you that you kill
yeah why why what was it that made all
of you guys
just I don't know what it was like from
the beginning it seemed like DJ Hazard
Frank sinarelli all of you guys were
just murderers
[__] murdered and there wasn't there
wasn't any Kenny Rogerson I'm trying to
think of anybody you don't gotta name a
name in there that would kind of just
you know hit a single to write and wait
for somebody everybody was just kind of
swinging for the fences yeah the
Northeast it's cold and I don't mean the
weather you know if you stumble on the
sidewalk it doesn't matter who's walking
by it could be a 90 year old nothing
right people laugh at you it's a mean
thing you think a little bit yeah
yeah I don't I don't know I I something
that uh
I'm very thankful that I started out and
uh I got to see you guys do anything so
how did you I never even I remember when
I used to open for you you were real
quiet so I get really intimidated and
you'd say Hey listen pal keep it to like
three or five [__] no no more let me
tell you that story that's how that
worked I love that it wasn't three or
four it'd be like three to five [__]
right right well first Michelle Polito
at the Kowloon told me one night watched
this new guy because she trusts me I'll
always be honest with her she said what
do you think of this [__] just let me
know what you think of this new guy Bill
Burr and I watched you at the collar and
I was watching and you did this one bit
that really got to me in a good way it
was about clouds
he was saying who is the first pilot
that saw a cloud and said let's fly
through this and we have the guys to go
through it and the other guy's saying no
no no it's going to destroy the plane I
thought that is brilliant you know that
is just brilliant and that won me over
and so then the next day a lot of people
used to call me up and say hey uh can
you recommend me to some Bookers I said
well you know it should be something
that I decide to do it shouldn't be
something you're leaning on me to do
right so I called uh without you now did
you have a problem saying that to people
yes you wouldn't say it that's sort of
lighter yeah I'll see what I can do
I'll get right on that yeah I'll get
right on that you know so because if
you're asking me chances are obviously
the answer is no otherwise I would have
done it by now I know and Louis C.K was
another guy he didn't ask me I saw him
and I said I like this kid and I I
called a couple of Bookers and I got him
into a couple of clubs you might not
remember it you might not remember it
but I called uh Pretty Polly uh Denise
Kirk that was one of the big phone calls
I ever got I remember when they called
me pretty Paulie used to book uh College
gigs and they were like hey Bill this is
so-and-so from pretty Paulie Mike
Donovan gave you a shout out and they go
do you know who we are I said yeah I
know you are I go you guys you guys go
to college and it happened fast a week
later she's oh it just so happens I got
something coming up at Dartmouth so we
took the ride to Darwin it was three and
a half hours it's a lot longer than
we're going to be here on this podcast
it's three and 3 15 each way and we got
there and it was uh three degrees and
windy it was one of the coldest nights
ever we had to park four blocks away but
you know you did a great job and it was
all uphill but let me just tell you one
thing I was I was watching one of your
specials last night you were talking
about how you were checking out the new
music because you figured well I'm going
to play this club so I'm something I'm
going to do Bill Burr's podcast
should I watch his specials because I'm
I live under a rock I'm a book where I'm
writing history books all the time that
is my life is history books right and
writing them and trying and
self-publishing them and I didn't know I
knew that you would become big but I
didn't know what you would become and
I'm thinking to myself what if I don't
like what I see what if I watch this
special and he's some nasty prick some
right-wing [__] or some left-wing
[__] or maybe he's mean-spirited or
maybe he's become hacky I don't know I
don't know I know that so you think
politically I'm in the middle yes thank
God because that's what I try to do
because I don't want to I don't wanna I
don't have the answers I don't want to
piss anybody else so I just sort of
trash both sides I gotta be honest with
you Liberals are more fun to trash
because they're not used to it we're
conservatives they're like ah [__] you
you guys always [__] on the when you
came into Knicks I I had the night
before you came into Nick's I didn't
know you were coming to town and uh I
had a dream that you were in my kitchen
talking to me and he handed me your
address and it was a long time that is
bizarre I haven't really thought about
Bill that much lately I know he's big I
haven't talked to him in ages and then
the next day I get a phone call from
Nick saying do you mind if Bill Burr
comes in and does a guest set and
without
hesitating I said yeah I think I do mind
he's going to destroy the place and then
they're going to boo me off the [__]
stage
and then I said uh and then Ryan said to
Ryan Cott said don't worry about it it's
going to be fine all right I just it was
just an initial reaction you know and
then you came in and I watched your set
you didn't hurt my set at all because
you know I couldn't you're Mike Donovan
well you're you're a mom I was also
nervous dude I went right back this was
last summer when I was getting I was
getting ready to do that gig that I had
in Boston so I wanted to do a little set
to warm up and I I remember I went right
back to being a little Billy Burr open
it for you and like Drake it you know I
was serious dude you got like you know
you got that face dude where you're just
sitting there you like that poker face
like I don't know what you're thinking
I'm just going like keep it to three or
five [__] don't piss off Mike Donovan
Mike Clark won't get me a Giggles
anymore I went right back to that and I
gotta tell you when I got off stage and
you said man really funny stuff like I
can't even tell you what a lift
that gave me because I hold all of you
guys
where you should be like the like you
guys built the scene that gave me a
career so when I was watching you and I
was watching you you have a wonderful
Rhythm and I was watching that uh but I
was noticing uh that you were
even-handed and that's a Lenny Bruce
quality and before we finish the show I
want to do a Lenny Bruce impression if
we can okay uh but I was one you were
even hand and there isn't a lot of that
out there there is there there's a lot
of people that don't do any political
leanings they're just hacks or whatever
or they just do their thing and it
doesn't touch on politics but you can
name a hundred right-wing redneck
Comedians and a hundred left-wing
liberal comedians I'd say a thousand
left way but they don't
they don't have a a moderate bone in
their body and they they never know how
to say uh well I changed my mind on that
I'm back and forth on that or I'm not
sure about that or I don't know enough
about that or I used to feel this way
and now I feel this way and call me
tomorrow I might feel differently about
it right because and I used to be on WBZ
Radio as a guest for for several years
before the pandemic hit and one of the
things that my co-host really liked what
I said was never let your opinion become
your identity
because then you have a vested interest
in not backtracking and not changing
your mind because now my ego's on the
line because I asserted myself on this
issue and now my opinion has become my
identity and I work very hard to always
be ready to change my mind in a
heartbeat on anything but anyway I was
noticing it was wonderful to see uh
anybody that was even-handed it's so
rare to me that's one of your
outstanding qualities and I think it's
uh not my good looks
of course it is no I I really appreciate
that because
um I think that like I I don't know I
don't know [__] right but when I see
people like just like in entertainment
tweeting their political opinions it's
just like why would you do that like
nobody gives a [__] nobody exactly you
know what dude just the way you said
nobody was beautiful
it's nobody you're yelling at nobody and
there's a couple of morons that will
yell back at you like last night we went
out to dinner my wife and I would uh a
couple uh great friends of ours and at
one point
I showed this this thing that somebody
had posted about how the the politicians
in the in the Senate the House
Representatives all crushed it last year
in the uh in the stock market you know
and everybody else like took a bath but
somehow they knew exactly what it you
know and he looked at it and he goes is
this true and I was like you know I
don't know someone just put it on
the internet
and he goes because you know I don't
know if that's true and I started to
argue with them then I just stopped I go
like why don't I just just [__] agree
with you that maybe it's not true
because I'm not going to change yours
and let's just enjoy dinner and we both
just started laughing because at the end
of the day like if you get sucked into
that thing where like I think this way
and you don't and I'm gonna convince you
to think the way I think like what the
[__] do I know so but back to that point
is that the person talking like you're
describing is never going to backtrack
and say you know I've changed my mind
about that well my friend actually
laughed and goes yeah you're right like
he's he's but nobody says you know well
tomorrow I might think differently about
every once you once you establish this
I'm a conservative or I'm a liberal
I write history books that's what I'm
self-publishing I'm what part of history
is is Fascinate You that that you're
writing well the uh World War II I've
always been interested when I was 12
years old I wasn't a very good student
but when it came to anything to do with
World War II this teacher would stand
next to me to make sure that no one
could steal my answers I couldn't slip
the answer I I knew I was an expert on
World War II when I was 12. but then I
forced myself to so you got an A in
history and F's and everything else uh
pretty much close enough but I have a
great Trilogy I've written called Who's
Who in World War II who's who in the
Civil War and who's who in Russian
history right now I'm on a binge on
Russian history I'm a wizard on Russian
history I'm available to be a teacher if
anybody wanted to hire me that's amazing
people say why don't you teach well it's
not that simple you don't just walk out
the door say anybody want to hire me to
be you know what's funny I actually
wanted to do that like one summer I
wanted to go back I went to Emerson
College and I was like I would love to
just teach a course because they have
like a comedy or performance course out
there and I was like I would love to
teach a course
on like stand-up comedy and just hang
out in Boston which I love eat the food
I love put on 40 pounds and then go down
there and help out you know these this
next generation of Comedians and then I
found ah you got to get certified you
got to do this right it's not that
simple yeah it's a long if somebody
heard this podcast and say this guy I
checked him out online I heard him he
sounds like somebody we could I mean I'm
available but I'm also available to just
live the rest of my life as I'm doing it
I'm not worrying about that but my
history books you wouldn't know I wrote
a a JFK a history I wrote a history of
every presidency not every president
every presidency I might be the only
difference between every president and
every presidency because the uh a
president's a presidency is a history of
the United States in that President's
time my books are called like the USA in
the time of JFK so it's not really about
JFK but it's divided by presidencies and
when if if you're in college or high
school and you're reading books about
American history it's always these large
Blended chapters that roll into each
other you know economics and the
pre-civil War era and you know education
but but but to have it nice and
organized uh one book at a time but
anyway the point is
a friend of mine was uh who's a
successful writer Jack Olson he wrote a
bunch of True Crime books but anyway
he's uh was looking at my stuff and he
sent it to one of his friends and he
asked his friend does this guy swing
from the left or the right
because the guy who read the whole book
and the guy said you know that's an
interesting question
I mean right there I'm in I'm in Gold
because he doesn't know he doesn't know
and he's perfect and he's thought about
he says I think he swings from the left
but just the way that what I just said
went down that says it all yeah I've
written a uh I got some e-books I've
published about I call it the heritage
of American slavery and it's a history
of uh mostly its stories and incidents
that have to do with slavery in American
history and you get tumbleweeds When you
mention it on social media because
everyone's a believe it or not this
might be hard to believe it doesn't have
any left-wing stink on it and it doesn't
have any right-wing patriotic stink on
it either it's just
stories it's old-fashioned history I'm
an old-fashioned guy I'm a bookworm I'm
up all night reading old-fashioned books
and I'm creating these history books and
this is my life this is this is why I'm
only a household name in the Boston area
until I got here this is the biggest
thing that ever happened for me and
that's not a backhanded compliment
because you're a special person I
appreciate that and I remember one time
just if you want to know about this guy
I remember when I was I was talking to
you
way back in the day
about some hell gig I did it out in Lee
Massachusetts and somebody threw a
[__] dinner roll at me and how pissed
I was when I left just humiliated and
you looked at me you go you know what I
do when I have a gig like that he go I
take the money and I go out from the
money from that gig I go out and buy
myself something nice it was back then
he goes there you go I had a gig like
that I went out and I bought a [__]
vcr and every time I pop a tape in I
think [__] you to that crowd I got it
right and I was just sitting there like
I was like that is such like a great
way to try to get something
um there was always that story and then
the Don Gavin the classic one where he
drove all the way up to Western
Massachusetts to play a fair and he
showed up
and he's like yeah hey I'm the comedian
where am I performing and they go ah we
figured you'd just stand right over here
get up on that picnic table
he goes you're gonna set up any chairs
they go no we just figured you'd start
doing your act and people would assemble
and he goes is there a microphone they
said no he goes okay great he goes you
know I got my props in the car I'm gonna
go
it's not a prop comic and he just got in
his car and drove home and I remember
thinking like I didn't know you could do
that right like I would have been like
well I don't want to piss off the people
at the fair and I would have stood there
and humiliated myself so that was
another thing that I liked about you
guys was the self-esteem
that if it was a [__] gig or
something happened you guys all had your
little thing like you know Don would
leave you're like I'll [__] do the
gig but I'm getting a VCR out of this
right I always just thought that was so
cool one of my favorite things in the
book that I mentioned is a a slogan I
have called don't forget this and this
is going out to aspiring comedians don't
forget your Shield
your Shield is your act if you're in a
situation that's noisy there's music
coming in from the Next Room the mic is
shorting out the the manager is being a
grouch and you like this sucks right how
am I going to get through this don't
forget your Shield you're not just going
up there as yourself you have an act
just do your act and that's your best
strategy to get through this difficult
situation that's how did you get the
nerve to do stand up being like you
remind me a little bit of myself or
believe it or not as much as I run my
yep I am introverted especially back
then right I was pretty walled off and
everything like that easy answer okay I
love doing impressions and that's what I
started out as and so I'm so uh thrilled
to get up on stage and do the
Impressions that the nervousness doesn't
even enter into can I do my best
impression Tony Soprano get the [__] out
of here up your ass
up your ass
all the conversation I get around here
must be a [__] dildo you know what
you got that this is the [__] up for
me even think about
[Music]
it and I was walking on the on the Walk
of Fame and I stepped on Charlton
heston's car and he went get your
stinking shoes off me you damn dirty
tourists
one more where did you start uh I
started out in Corning New York I was a
disc jockey I was a top 40 disc jockey I
didn't know that oh yeah
wekt 98.5 FM hammondsport bath I started
off in radio College radio oh yeah I was
uh you're listening to 88.9 we no 88
yeah 88.9 wrs Boston a broadcast service
of Emerson College and before that
I was on 6 40 a.m wecb which only went
to the dorms and I had the two to six a
shift that was nobody listening anybody
has any requests like they were
listening to me and I remember
at one point I was almost done with my
shift and I was like I was just
exasperated and I finally just said you
know just call in just tell me you hate
me I don't care just something and I
think lit up and I picked it up and this
guy goes I hate you
yeah I got a couple then I hung up and I
sat there like thinking the whole world
was listening and he was actually the
boyfriend of the girl that had the 6 a.m
shift so they were just listening to
hear if I was still on the radio yeah
dude Shrek request yes I do will you
please leave town yeah I got all of that
I used why am I I used to host the Jazz
Oasis ice on on wers and those [__]
Jazz fans were the worst that you would
ask for a requests they wouldn't request
anything and then I would play something
and then some old dude would call it man
this isn't Jazz who the [__] it's just
like well give me a request you I
shouldn't have to and then they would
hang up on me and I would be sitting
there like it was Charles Mingus I
thought I couldn't go wrong with that
but I I picked one of those um
those late 60s early 70s where they
completely just were playing like free
form and yeah I like that stuff it was
do you have I can't get too crazy let's
talk about your book though that I
cannot wait to read because I already
was going through this this Santa rally
Frank santarelli Mark Scalia
yeah you guys all I started out Kenny
Rogerson you guys should know these
names by the way and then you even had
because Chris Rock you have all of these
stories
um I actually saw Bill Downs yeah Billy
down Billy down shout out to Billy Downs
gave me a lot of my uh first gigs dick
Doherty rest his soul
um it's a fun read it's not
comprehensive it does it's not a history
of stand-up comedy it's not how to do
stand-up comedy it's not entirely a
biography it's not entirely about the
Bostons it's all over the road and
there's a lot of uh I I have stacks of
index cards that's partly how I
maintained a level of quality in my
actors is always listen every time every
show I ever did I listened to you did
every show I ever did not in the last 10
years but up while I was you know coming
up every show I listened to and I'd stop
and take notes and write them down on
index cards you know and some in the
book there's a lot of my index cards
where I I go word for word on the end
and then I translate it because
sometimes it's like it's insured yeah
and so it's like notes from shows like
for example example uh I I'll have I'll
find an index card 98 on 89 that means
it's 1998 and I'm listening to a show
from 1989 and I'm making notes and I'm
going you didn't have to snap at that
crowd you didn't have to snap at that
Heckler he meant well what the hell is
wrong with you this is this is you talk
to yourself like you're somebody else
like you didn't have to do that that's
hilarious oh yeah sure
yeah wait so in 1998 you went back and
listened to piles of tapes and you I
always gain things from old shows like
hey that's a a breadcrumb that fell off
the table oh yeah yeah and also if if
you have a joke that you did in 1989 and
you're listening to it now on a very old
tape you go if I brought that joke back
now word for word it didn't change a
thing I would do it three times better
because of my experience
I would pay to listen to tapes of stand
up like real stand-up not the [__] that
I saw on TV where everyone's doing their
you know their TV set
just to hear
you know just is a fan of stand up like
how many hours you must have like oh
it's endless and the and laughs are
beautiful and Lenny Bruce said this
about you you can't fake a laugh Lenny
Bruce said if you tried to fake a left
they'd lock you up into a lunatic asylum
and I thought people notice and you
notice but I thought about that and I
said and ever since then this is I went
on a Lenny Bruce binge in the mid 80s I
was going to the libraries before the
internet I'm printing out stuff from The
New York Times and
ever since that day I've been watching
actors and I've never seen an actor
recreate a real laugh never not even one
and every time I watch a movie or a TV
show and an actor has to laugh I'm like
this is painful it's so fake it's a
laugh has a perfect Rhythm like the
Pistons of an engine and whenever an
actor is doing
it's not even it's uneven it's the
toughest thing uh actor once told me you
know anger is the easiest thing to do do
in the world as an actor oh that's right
angers
not exactly not exactly all right let me
swing around to another point I was
starting on earlier can we talk about
the laughs though I'll tell you a left
it's a legit laugh yeah that I feel like
the actor was improving so the other guy
was laughing was it was Harvey Keitel
and rest his soul one of my favorite
actors Chris Penn
um and they were sitting in the car and
he was telling this story
uh about you know some Mexican guy and
you could tell he was improv and
everyone in the cars becemi you could
see they were really laughing and what I
loved about
Chris Penn he's just you could just see
like this guy knows how to tell a story
like he's just like you know like an oak
tree like rooted in the ground and you
just like drawn in there's been a couple
of those another Harvey Keitel one is if
you watch
um
uh Thelma and Louise
um I always forget the guy's name the
guy who plays Daryl in that uh when he's
like what
wait what like Harvey could tell is just
laughing like he can't control himself
right if the person has a quirky laugh
that comes out easily yeah you can they
can do it in a movie but it's but I know
I know what you're saying okay now he he
says something and they also they always
laugh too soon drives me out of my mind
you haven't even heard the entire punch
line but you know as an actor you you're
supposed to laugh and they laugh before
that might be the editor though it might
not be the comedian because they
condense it because I'll tell you what
blow no but I mean in real time I see it
all the time they just laugh too soon
but let me finish
I was worried about not liking you
because you know seriously but I knew I
dug you initially you know but I didn't
know what you would become see I live
under a rock I'm always I'm reading
history books all day I live under a
rock too believe it but I don't know
who's famous uh most of the comedians
today I don't know who they are actors
most of the uh but as far as comedians
go amongst all the greats there's only
25 percent of them that I like you know
most of them I don't like it seems most
of the comedians love all the other
Comedians and I don't I I'm easily
pissed off by stuff that I think is
hacky or vicious or mean
there's an intangible to a there's like
a spirituality to a person's Act is this
person just trying to be funny is it
mean-spirited and everyone was talking
about you saying oh yeah he's angry he's
angry he's got this [__] you attitude he
reminds me a little bit of humor he's
got this [__] you attitude so I wasn't
sure what I was going to find and and so
I watched you and I was
I was moved because you are not just
angry you're nice
you you are everybody's friend there's
something intangible about you where
you're mean and nasty but you're also
kind and and you're reaching out in a
more defensive than Ang but people just
say oh yeah there's something really
nice about you I appreciate that I'm not
good at taking compliments but I I just
stand up it's very rare to be edgy and
nice at the same time I'm not sure I've
ever pulled that off I'm a little edgy
I'm not sure well I will tell you that I
don't want anybody leaving not having a
good time sometimes if you just bring up
a topic like there's no way to please
people like I did this thing for Netflix
uh you know friends who kill
Ed and I went up there and I was just
doing like topical stuff because I was
like well this stuff isn't going to live
long enough for my next special so I'll
do some of this stuff
and I did something about some kid that
shot a gun or whatever and like the
level of
you know he shot a you know kill two
people or whatever and the level of
people saying how unfunny I was I was
like no but I realized that it was like
because
I made fun of something that they were
into like they thought I was going after
what amendment is it with the guns is it
the second yeah fifth I always forget
plead the Fifth Fifth though I forget
who gives a [__] right here
um
the Second Amendment and it's just like
I don't give a [__] I like guns I don't
care if they have a gun but this
particular guy was an idiot so I was
making fun of him and then you get to
those people who just can't you know
there's some that they were like that
was quite possibly the most unfunny six
minutes of my life and that's when I
started to realize like of your life
you're old enough to remember 9 11. 911
was more enjoyable than my six minutes
on this [__] jerk off with a gun all
right
so
um
but it bothered me because I don't want
people
to do that I want people like what I
loved about Richard Pryor was when he
made fun of white people he did it in a
way that got me to laugh at myself which
made me open to what he was saying where
if somebody came the other way
you know like that I would always be
like all right this guy hates white
people uh you know [__] you I'm not
listening to you so I I try to do it
like um do you remember there was there
was a period of time and stand up where
walking the crowd was like this badge of
honor right and I used I never
understood that I was like well once
they leave the funds over right like the
game is to annoy them
[Music]
but still keep them on the hooks Ray
Garvey used to book in Atlantic City he
said any comic that doesn't walk a table
now and then isn't a real comic as far
as I'm concerned which is a great
statement but it's essential that the
phrase now and then is in there you
don't want to consistently walk people
but once in a blue moon somebody should
uh go ah well I never right but that's
another thing too it's like what's wrong
with just being silly oh of course I've
really come into this new period of
enjoying I've always loved silly but
like I find that if you add silliness to
a really serious topic it's it's like
magic like you're just being
like domestic violence the other night I
was talking about it and I was just
being over the top silly and sexist but
it was so [__] silly that everybody
could laugh at me it breaks the tension
like my newest joke I might never do it
is uh I'm not going to mass anymore I'm
sick of all these mass shooting I'm
afraid
I don't know if that one would work it
might not I feel like people get the
mass shooting thing is it depends on the
crowd if if you work in a a a a a rough
crowd they don't care and Boston's
pretty right
you know well so this is you know what I
like about this book already is you're
telling me that I can kind of basically
just even if I like it with my ADD I
could just yeah it's totally browsable
there's no essential Grand motive to it
and you know there's no grand theme it's
just comedy collection of biographies
like my I call it the micropedia of
stand-up comedy but there's a ton of
people that aren't in there it's just I
just I enjoy writing what what year did
you start I my first show was in 1975 at
Wet Goods in Corning New York I did an
hour and 20 minutes
1975. yeah but what was the scene like
back then well there was no scene there
was it was uh catch a rising star in New
York and I went down there to try to do
it down there
so you went on that that Fame that's
like the famous one and then everybody
would hang out with the green kitchen or
something like that on the east side I
always heard about that place I don't
remember that one but the guy that was
the coolest guy in the world to all the
comedians was Richard Belzer he was the
king of comedy as far as we were all
concerned he hosted open mics at the
catch a rising star and he'd be on stage
four hours
he brought me up on stage and he stood
there uh working the crowd while I was
standing next to him
like he hadn't even mentioned my name
yet but if it was anyone else I would
have been insulted I didn't care I'm
standing next to Richard Belzer he was
like he was the king of comedy I
remember like 30 years ago
when he booked that procedural show that
he he has like the record for being on
TV like the longest time in a row or
something like that longest years in a
row I remember him standing going yeah
they're offering me this thing you guys
think I should do it he was joking
around obviously he was going to do it
so I always feel cool like I was like
um I saw him right before he got that
that what the f what show is that I
never
oh it is he's on one of the lawn orders
right
um and then uh I remember seeing what
was it Jimmy Fallon
uh we were at the Tempe Improv and it
was right when he got The Tonight Show
and he was doing stand-up you know he
get ready to do like monologues and
stuff like that and I remember talking
to him as he was
like trying to get his head around the
fact that he was the uh the new host of
The Tonight Show I like that's one of my
favorite things about being in this
business is to be there right before you
see you know a friend of yours or
someone you admire blow up like that and
um yeah I used to hang out with Steven
Wright when he was working in uh at the
in Cambridge
and it's just to see what happened to
him was wonderful for the most part the
best people do get the best breaks I
think you know yeah but it's not an
accident they happen to be the best
people occasionally there's a dick that
goes far but most of the people that go
far are nice and that's part of why they
went far right but I what I like about
you and Stephen Wright is I relate to
you guys in that despite what you do for
a living you like your alone time oh
yeah and like I've talked to uh Steven
Wright one time I can't even believe I
got to talk to him
he was telling me how much he likes to
be alone that he actually called the
post office to see if he could legally
stop getting mail like this is how much
he doesn't want to get bugged and they
were like no sir you have to have a
legal address and like I don't know if
it's it's being around crowds and all of
that stuff that after a while you you
kind of love that alone time and I keep
having like this reoccurring dream
like not like I'm a sleep dream but just
of having a house in the middle of
nowhere
and just sitting on the porch with like
a cup of coffee oh absolutely or a cigar
and just not having anything to do or
anybody to talk to obviously my wife and
kids are there
um right and just like hanging out with
them simple living yes
yes which is why I can't relate to a lot
of the
um you know capitalism was always
selling you that you needed the next
thing but like nowadays
um like that whole you know grinding 24
7 and you know money never sleeps and
all of that [__] it's just like uh that
is not a road from how I'm wired that's
not going to be a road to happiness you
know walking around wearing some
chinchilla coat and never
I don't have any free time like I don't
understand
like what the purpose of that is but um
I got so much out of guys like you when
I was coming up and uh I really cannot
wait to read this book and you you've
always been like one of the great guys
to have a conversation with when I got
over you're very intimidating guy just
no be well what it is is you're quiet
and introverted so what happens is is if
you're an insecure person you
immediately go like oh he's not talking
to me because he doesn't like me because
I was quiet and introverted and the
people used to look at me going like ah
people think you're aloof and that was
the funniest thing to me it's like
because you don't talk to when I first
came in I was really shy especially in
New York I was just I was scared
and um
you know I remember seeing how people
think you're aloof and it's just like if
they realized that when I was sitting
over the corner not talking to them
because I was questioning everything I
did in the last seven minutes of my life
um it was something I had to learn I'll
tell you how quiet I've never told the
story I did a show in Pennsylvania
I think it was Scranton it was one of
those old cities
and it's Friday night and I did good on
Friday night it's first time at the club
and after the show they came up to me
shook me you were great he says we were
thinking about firing you like what
says we were talking to the management
down in New York City and we thought you
were so quiet that you couldn't possibly
they weren't joking yeah they were
discussing it at two o'clock in the
afternoon whether to have me replaced
just based on the fact that I was that
quiet sitting in the corner reading a
history book oh my God like and and I
didn't say anything minutes said I was
thinking you [__] [__] you didn't
even give me a chance then I was I was
in Gold because I did go downstairs
right you know I I light up on stage in
a pretty quiet off stage unless I'm
watching The Three Stooges or somebody I
think is hilarious you know I can get a
phone call from the hotel management you
got to keep the Laughing down right
because it's not like I don't have a
sense of humor but I have a high
standard for what's funny you know what
that reminds me of one time I had a gig
and I was living in La the first time
and it was uh I was playing Atlantic
City and the plane was late I landed in
Newark and I got a rental car and I was
one of my first headlining gigs and I'm
driving like a madman to get down there
and I make it down there just in time
and I come walking and I say the guy hey
you know hey so-and-so uh uh Bill Burr
I'm the headliner he goes oh
he's like you look nervous yeah right
and it's just like and I just
immediately just felt what little energy
I had drained out of me and I was just
thinking like I have to work for this
[__] [__] all weekend but I was old
enough that I knew
I was like this guy is miserable
and this has nothing to do I was just
starting to learn that but this is the
thing I still needed his approval and he
never quite gave it to me really the
whole weekends yes so the whole weekend
I just felt like he was leaning on me
and
um you know those Casino gigs are not
easy gigs when you first start because
it's this
this sort of cross population if you're
not used to doing the road your act's
going to be a little Regional and then
also very age appropriate I was a young
guy in my 20s and these people you know
had just lost money and they were in
their 50s yes why don't you smile more
put a hidden camera on me leave the room
I'll brighten right up yeah exactly why
don't you [__] off for a minute
um unfortunately oh look at that we're
coming to the end of them um I also have
a Lenny Bruce book I've written I was
going to ask you if if you if you uh
wrote one because I didn't realize
like I knew that guy was great obviously
but like I he he did this bit on Jackie
Kennedy oh yeah that was great she
wasn't trying to help the Secret Service
man aboard she was hauling ass to save
her ass just like anybody else and I
wouldn't want my wife to have to live up
to that standard because it's all
[__] right and he did that
in like the beginning of 64. like that
literally happened in November in six
five six months later he was already
making jokes about it and to to hear him
do it and actually hear people laughing
was
um
it was one of those those great things
we like people really haven't changed
because that's the kind of thing that
somebody you know back in the day the
comedy seller when I was down there and
I would watch all these great Comics
like Louie and all of them like they
would have Colin would have a bit about
that
like I'm oh man I remember calling like
the best he had the best [__] 911
joke
of how people were trying to be like
sort of like
make it seem like they were almost in
the towers and each example got more and
more ridiculous like somehow they would
like literally like they couldn't set
their ego aside I'm totally butchering
it but they they had to make not even
911 had to be about them and he was
doing that like on like September 20th
or whatever like nine ten days after it
happened and he was killing with it and
um you know there's there's a thing
where you watch comedians from way back
then you know take my wife please and
you see that you just think it's all
this you didn't realize that like no
there was guys
you know Lenny red fox and all these
guys were just
slinging it the same way people do it
now that you just could not get on TV
saying stuff there was no HBO but like
people
were were joking about that stuff and
you had like no idea his stuff on like
uh
uh homosexuality and all of that that
stuff he did live at Carnegie Hall oh
yeah yeah and I'm just sitting there
going oh that's silly he had to but
that's tremendously silly but the the
the the Dustin Hoffman movie and that
awful book by Albert Goldman and a lot
of these documentaries they might be
loving documentaries and they're taking
This heavyweight meaning to what he was
to society and everything but they
forget about how silly it was and I at
this back before even before CDs I had
made this uh cassette tape the best of
Lenny Bruce my homemade uh mixtape yeah
my Lenny Bruce and I handed it to
comedians all the time I was like the
Lenny Bruce Johnny Appleseed I would
hand it to Comedians and I swear every
time the comic would come back to me two
months later and say Mike I never
realized how [__] funny he is
yeah he was amazing because people are
so focused on the seriousness of his
life story and how he defied society and
redefine this and that and there's a lot
of truth to all of that but he was also
hilarious and people don't realize just
how [__] and his stuff stands up like
like oh the the Carnegie Hall he kind of
screws around for like the first 10
minutes but right around 10 11 minutes
what he goes into his act like I was
listening and you you forget that it was
I mean that was in the 50s or 60s that
he did that I can't remember when he did
it but I you know this is back when I I
had my uh I had a CD player in my car
and I popped it in and I was like wow
like this guy's stuff was still
contemporary Woody Allen comedian was
another one that was still like
contemporary and I think it's because
those guys were like talking about life
in like an honest way
um it really is amazing but um dude I so
enjoyed having you on the podcast and
and and you know all these years I've
known you actually got to know you even
better like knowing that you're a
history buff and all of that and and I
got to get those World War II books I'm
on Mike Donovan's bookstore on Facebook
that's the only place I promote myself
with an apostrophe Mike Donovan's
bookstore on Facebook
d-o-n-o-v-a-n and the name of the book
is the stand-up comedy book and it's a
good read that's all it is it's just
it's for people who like to if you don't
like to read don't buy the book it's for
readers seriously it's a book you know
it's not for people that just don't like
to read and think I love stand-up comedy
yeah if you appreciate good writing I'm
a pretty good writer I think you're an
excellent writer and I can't wait to uh
I can't wait to read this Mike it was an
absolute honor yeah I know I have you on
the podcast it was an honor to all you
know open for you and learn from you I'm
a big fan and you know after watching
you last time when I get back to Boston
I'm going to watch all your specials
because I just simply want to enjoy
myself well can you just I'm worried
that you're gonna watch the older ones
I'll probably like them better
all right thank you so great to see you
the stand-up comedy book Mike Donovan he
also has uh what is it uh World War II
who's who in World War II who's who
Civil War who's winning the Civil War
and who's who in Russian history Russian
history they're all about a hundred
thousand words long they're fairly big
books how many pages uh 350 400 they're
big books well I want to read the
Russian history because I know they
whack that family and they finally found
him right they buried him didn't they
well the best story about that is the
chill the the girls they kept shooting
them and they wouldn't die and they
didn't understand when they were and
they turned it turned out they when they
examined the body they had all the
Family Jewels hidden in their corsets
there's a lot of good stories in there
about Russian history yeah I I love that
book all right the who's who are the of
uh yeah and the 12 font version is
called Mike Donovan's uh people of
Russian history but and the uh the
e-book is called Who's Who in Russian
history all right well you are an
absolutely amazing comedian and a
fascinating guy to talk to I can't wait
to read this when I go from this I'm
going to Russian and I'll pump all that
on the podcast anytime you're out here
or anytime I'm back in Boston if you
want to come back on the podcast I would
love to great to have your respect sir
oh right back at you Mike Donovan
everybody thank you so much for uh
listening to the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast uh
have a great weekend you [__]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
um January 26 2015 what's going on how
are you how's it going
um I am doing this at about 10 41 P.M
Monday night in Perth
Perth Australia
sorry you guys have to deal with my
awful Australian accent
um and also the shitty recording thing
that I'm going to use this week because
I was not lugging my [__]
mixer all the way over here I remember I
had a flat I was packing up the mixer
and uh last time I I was in Australia I
remember I [__]
I plugged in the mixer and uh it got all
shorted out even though I had the thing
to uh the adapter
whatever the [__] you call it
anyways I'm in a [__] hotel room
right now
and uh it's gross I'm in a gross [__]
hotel room right now
um
I don't even know where to begin to
describe first of all the little [__]
round coffee table I had to wipe the
whole thing down
from the sticky drinks from the last
time
and uh then the [__] the rug is just
like I'm trying to find an area of the
rug that isn't stained overrated
everybody the Hyatt
the [__] Hyatt I remember when I was
a kid
you know the [__] Hyatt even like a
Hilton was considered nice now granted I
grew up in a family that you know a
number of times a month
we had chip beef on toast or chicken a
la king for dinner
the scalloped potatoes and ham
this is before the Food Network so
whatever whatever the [__] recipes were
handed down or on the back of a [__]
Rice Krispie box that's what you ate
if you think about some of the [__] you
had
ugh
we had this [__]
goulash Hungarian goulash that was
actually good then we had this other
[__] my mother used to put these [__]
noodles in it
and one day my older brother told me
they were actually worms and every time
I went to eat it I'd be like [__]
gagging my mother didn't give a [__]
she'd make me finish it I can't believe
I can't remember the name of it anyways
whatever but back in the day you know
a height and a Hilton what nice now I
don't know what happened I don't think
they've bought a rug much less shampooed
one
every time I'm thinking I'm staying at
the Hyatt I always saw the Hyatt this is
going to be great it's still stuck in my
head
like way back in the [__] day
this place is a [__]
um anyways but I am excited to be out
here this is the furthest into uh
Australia that I've ever been nice
14-hour flight to Sydney
and then uh we landed
and uh
[__] went into a hotel
hung out for part of the day and then I
had to do
um some big talk show I didn't remember
the name of it I'm so [__] jet-lagged
it was weird it was weird we uh this is
how we taped the thing I went down into
a conference room in the hotel
and they had me sitting in the room and
then in another room they had the camera
that I just looked into and talk
and um
that person in there was in a room with
the light shutout so I look like some
crazy person when my wife came in
because I was sitting there with the
light on me talking into a dark room
and um trying to be pleasant but it was
actually a really fun show I wish I
could have done it live
so
um anyway so I'll be letting you guys
know my [__] Adventures over here as
I go like I said I'm starting off here
in Perth I believe the next night is in
Melbourne Melbourne however the [__] you
say it
and um
then Brisbane and then Sydney
and then I'm done that's going to take a
week and then I'm over to New Zealand
then up to Singapore Hong Kong and then
the [__] Mumbai India
then over to New York to go do the uh
the Patrice O'Neal benefit
so there you go that's gonna be my
goddamn week
um
all right the [__] can I talk about
other than just being a goddamn plane
for the last [__] day of my life
Where Do We Begin
Where Do We Begin did anything happen
this week I don't know if you guys saw
this week I was on the bill my show
um I don't think I've ever felt so dumb
in my life
you know I felt like when I was on Bill
Marshall I felt like if I went on ESPN
and I didn't watch sports that's what it
felt like everybody throwing out these
[__] stats it was like fantasy
football except they were talking about
terrorism
or jails or something I don't even know
um
did the Larry Wilmore show too
first one I had a great time on that one
and that was another one
this politician from New Jersey was just
firing out these [__] little 85
percent of black males uh that they
don't have enough toothpicks in their
life and uh you know if you're a white
male you got plenty of
everybody nodding in a grad no [__]
idea what anybody was talking about and
you're probably saying well Bill you
know you dumb
you know you're not you know a Meet the
Press kind of [__] person either on a
real or a fake news show why the [__]
would you go do those gigs because
everybody I am promoting a movie
um that comes out January 30th called
Black or White that stars Kevin Costner
Octavius Spencer
and was written by Mike binder
and directed by Mike binder and
um
had a great time working on that thing
and
you know the Classic Hollywood didn't
want to make it
Kevin Costner loved the story he's
worked with Mike binder before on a
movie called Upside of Anger and he's
Costner said [__] it we're gonna make
this movie and he ended up putting up
his own money so
um if you have the time
and you have you know 20 or 30 close
friends if you could drag them out to
the local Cineplex
and uh buy a ticket watch it legally and
that type of thing that would be awesome
I would really appreciate it's called
Black or White I actually play a lawyer
I play Kevin Costner's lawyer Anthony
Mackey's in it I mean come on
and soon to be star Jillian Estelle is
in it I mean it's just it's a veritable
who's who except for me
somehow I snuck in there
um should I tell the story Bill how did
you get the part in that movie uh you
know what the Conan O'Brien show
I was on Conan running my Yap and my
binder had a friend who was watching and
said hey you got to see this guy this
guy's funny binder watched it and said
hey you know what that's the guy that's
Rick Reynolds and I didn't even have to
audition for it and I [__] went up to
New Orleans when we shot it and I had no
idea
what I was getting myself into as far as
uh
I'm trying to think when I even read the
[__] thing
when I even read the script I think I
read it as I was flying out there
you know
because that's where I am in this
business
if you say I have a movie I say yes
before you even tell me what it's about
speaking of which I had another one that
came out I actually did a
a zombie verse it's a movie about
beavers that turn into zombies
okay and if that doesn't get your ass
off the couch I don't think anything
will
um you know people try to give me [__]
about that movie like zombies what the
[__] do like we didn't know that it was
a joke going into it a friend of mine
Jordan Rubin Reuben I used to do uh
stand up with him like 20 [__] years
ago in New York called me up and said
hey Bill I'm uh doing this movie
um it's [__] over the top it's crazy
it's ridiculous I was wondering if you
would just do a one scene in it and I
said yes and I did a scene with somebody
else who's in Disguise who's actually
super famous
and I'm actually hearing really good
things about that thing but [__]
radio guys like to break my balls about
it
like I called up uh
wbcn in Boston toucher and Rich Show
Morning Show
toucher was breaking my balls about it
you know people see it it's it's a red
flag
you know you got a movie called zombie
verse they start looking at you like
Bill did you [__] did you blow a guy
in this did you do a little bit of porn
um
but whatever uh so those are the two but
black or white comes out January 30th I
know I'm pouring myself out right out of
the gate but if you guys would go see
it'd be really really important it's a
great movie great story and a lot of
these kinds of movies don't get made
anymore because nobody pays for movies
anymore
which is why movies either cost they
have like a [__] 500 000 budget or a
500 million because they're either like
not going to invest a lot of money
anymore or they're going to try to make
something
like those Transformers superhero
[__] movies
because they're betting on the fact that
you're going to be like well I gotta go
see that at the theater
um
I don't know I don't know how the whole
[__] thing works out but you know the
deal everybody steals everything now
people put the [__] money up so who
knows what
um so anyways this is the Monday Morning
podcast
um
let's see what the [__] happened this
week no this is the off week
the [__] off week between the AFC and
NFC championship games
and uh and the Super Bowl
so
you know there's never anything to talk
about so this week they had the whole
stupid deflategate thing which I don't
even really want to talk about it was so
[__] stupid
you know what I mean it was almost like
ESPN should have got sued
or whatever you know you're not supposed
to cry like you're not supposed to yell
fire in a crowded movie theater that's
literally what they were doing
it was the stupidest for the [__] the
Colts lost by 38 goddamn points you know
what's funny some guy on ESPN one of
those science guys actually uh
you know did this whole scientific
experiment thing
um
to see if uh
I'll actually post this video and I
always say this but this time I actually
will to see if it was an advantage it
actually turned out to be a slight
disadvantage the ball got there like a
split second later and they said it was
enough
for a Defender to get a fingertip more
in the way of the path of the ball I
mean it was so [__] stupid
I swear to God man
I'm trying to come up with a theory here
I just think
generally speaking people are sick of
the Patriots and they [__] hate Bill
Belichick and I know right now that you
guys are going to roll your eyes and
whatever I understand that you're like
this guy's a [__] Patriots fan I
don't want to hear it well just hear me
out here
this is what I love about Bill Belichick
is even in the press conference after
the game and the press conference before
his next game it's already part of his
game plan
everybody always sits there and they
talk about how he's so boring are you
listen to these [__] idiots on sports
radio they try to say that he's a
joyless man
because he just goes up there and I'd be
like uh hey you got you got Seattle
coming up you know well
what do you think about them man you
guys are favored do you think he can
beat him and I'll just be like oh you
know all right uh
have a great team I know I gotta work
gotta work cut out first ourselves
he would do that if you were playing
like the [__] Tampa Bay Buccaneers
and other great team and uh it's gonna
be a tough game
got our work got out for ourselves he
knows what he's doing
okay because Sports media
they're lazy their pieces of [__] and
they [__] take whatever you say and
they only they only [__] take a clip
of it and they twist it around and his
bulletin board material
for the other team or it creates a
[__] controversy and a distraction in
the locker room so he gives them nothing
so they don't like them so they're
looking to take the piss out of them you
know who the media loves they love a guy
like Rex Ryan
who's gonna [__] come up and just be
like we're gonna win the Super Bowl I
wrote it on a bus right
right there Rex Ryan will write 16
articles for you in one [__] one
press conference he's going to give you
your whole [__] season and as a
writer you don't even have to work you
just put your feet up all right either
he does it and he's like Babe Ruth
calling the Home Run shot or he fails
and we get to take the piss out of him
done Bill pelicek gives him nothing we
make some [__] work he makes him
actually watch the goddamn game
um
that was the biggest non-fucking story
I've ever heard and uh you know I'm over
here I went on uh
newyorkpost.com and I saw how Richard
Sherman was kind of mentioning
trying to suggest that we have this
[__] special relationship with the
commissioner I love how people
do you see the Dirtbag [__] that they're
doing
do you know the Seattle Seahawks have
had the most people test positive for
performance enhancing drugs
since 2011 including Richard Sherman who
also tested positive and then he said oh
it was a banned substance and uh I took
a sip off of of another player's drink
you know what I mean and uh I sipped it
I didn't know it was in there so he got
out of it
now I'm gonna choose to believe him
okay if I can choose to believe him why
can't he give us the [__] benefit of
the doubt really that's why it's in
there you took a sip of your buddy's
drink
who [__] Mr blonde who then did the
time for you and he did it like a man
he's gonna come in here
and decide out of the [__] blue
um give me a [__] break okay Seattle
Seahawks with their goddamn Stadium
that makes their their crowd sound
louder than it is is that cheating
your own [__] coach who got busted so
bad in the NCAA they actually took a
championship away from the guy
and this is the [__] thing
I'm not a Seahawks fan and I don't give
a [__] about any of that [__]
I don't give a [__] if Richard Sherman
was hurt and he did a [__] cycle to
get through it I don't give a [__] I
think they ought to be able to do it
I said that on Bill Martin [__] NFL
players ought to be able to take
steroids and the other people smoke weed
after the [__] game they gotta be
able to heal up their bodies and [__]
you know smoke a little weed take away
some of the pain and there's actually
arguments out there that say in the
medicinal purposes of the [__] drug
could actually you know
combat Alzheimer's in this new study
saying that I don't know if it's [__]
true but I just think if you're gonna
like beat the [__] out of your body
these [__] adonises that with two
fingers could throw me across the room
in their 20s and in their 40s
couldn't [__] beat me in a foot race
you know
across a [__] hotel lobby
I mean I just feel like these guys the
damage that they do to their bodies
it shortens their lives and the quality
of life that they're going to have when
they are alive like I really think that
they ought to be able to
like steroids are it's almost like
medicine
I don't know that's just my feeling and
hey you want to build a [__] stadium
that makes your crowd louder than it is
that's not against the rules but it's
kind of a what the [__] considering that
Seattle was unbeatable at home and was
pretty [__] human on the road for a
couple of years now
I still don't even give a [__] about
that and as far as that Pete Carroll
breaking all those [__] rules to the
point that they took away a Heisman
Trophy and a national championship
you know old Sneaky Pete
[__] sitting there telling Mark
Sanchez Sanchez that he was leaving
College too soon and then all of a
sudden the ncaa's at the front door and
he sneaks out the back door like a
[__] rat and abandons all those
goddamn kids that you know he told when
they signed their scholarships that he
wasn't [__] going anywhere he saved
his own ass and he ran out the back
[__] door and you know what that's
division one college football that's how
it's [__] done I don't give a [__]
I look at Pete Carroll like he just he
got caught
you know he might have been a little
worse or a little less who the [__]
knows
but just the way it works it's the way
it [__] works
so the same way your defensive back
grabs a handful of Jersey and then the
announcers go hey you know if you can
get away with it you know good for you
it's the same [__] thing so you got
all that [__] going on this is what
kills me Seattle's actually going to be
riding into the Super Bowl wearing the
white hat which is [__] hilarious to
me
because they're just as filthy as
anybody else including the [__]
Patriots give me a [__] break
do you realize these people who actually
sit there and call the Patriots cheaters
do you realize
that your entire [__] argument is
based on Eric Mangini and [__] Jim
ersei
okay
not exactly the most upstanding citizens
I know I've talked about Jim rce before
but I'll talk about the guy again that
guy could not beat the [__] Patriots
his team could not beat the Patriots 10
years ago
we [__] manhandle those receivers
during this game he bitched about it
Peyton Manning bitched about it to the
refs after the game the refs are like
whatever it was legal the [__] Pro
Bowl comes along Peyton Manning is still
bitching about it after the Super Bowl
ursay and they they make a [__] tape
and they send it to the league and the
league goes the Patriots did nothing
wrong
that is legal Jim Murphy sat on the
rules committee in the very next year
the way the Patriots were covering the
[__] Colts was now suddenly illegal
and after five yards you couldn't touch
him and you just had to escort him down
the field and they had Peyton Manning in
his prime well guess what the Colts beat
the Patriots and then they won a Super
Bowl
is that cheating is that gamesmanship
and as far as the Spygate thing goes
there was a League wide memo telling
everybody to stop doing it
okay just stop having a [__]
cameraman standing down there on the
sidelines in front of all the fans they
told everybody to stop doing it Eric
Mangini [__] built his resume doing
that [__]
oh Jesus somebody's rang the door am I
gonna get in trouble here
whatever so give me a [__] break so
the Patriots get caught and then all of
a sudden they question their entire
[__] uh Legacy
oh and then meanwhile we go off and win
like [__] 13 games every goddamn year
for the rest of the [__] time and
then people like well you didn't win a
Super Bowl and it's like oh yeah that
has nothing to do with our defense that
has to do with the fact that we weren't
[__] filming people give me a goddamn
break because I'll tell you this right
now if just filming the other team
got you a goddamn Dynasty every [__]
team in the league would still be doing
it they'd be just doing it right up from
the coaches box there's no camera with
the zoom on it and if you think people
aren't [__] doing that now stealing
goddamn signs absolutely they are
hang on a second there's somebody here
hold on hold on hold on hold on
hello
oh hey room service all right
set it down like that
all right you just put it right there on
the table right there right here this
table this table
yeah beautiful
um sorry about that there you go you
like that that was actual room service
captured on a podcast
um so whatever all you guys out there
all you Patriot haters you can run all
your [__] you guys can run your mods all
you want I don't give a [__]
okay your team's doing [__] too
okay I love how only we get questioned
about that stuff
the saints were taking out bounties
on other players does anybody question
their Super Bowl title I don't
you know
did you guys see Fran Tarkington losing
his mind he's still talking about Super
Bowl nine
when he showed up and he talked to his
lineman was it Stu Voit is that what's
the guy's name it's like a Hall of Famer
and he's looking over at the Steelers
and he's looking at looking at the
Vikings and he just goes how come he's
so much bigger than we are
it turns out later like 90 of them were
on roids including Terry Bradshaw who
admitted that he was on reut
ERS does anybody question the [__]
super Steelers of the 70s no
so go [__] yourself if you're going to
be sitting here talking about goddamn
walls that weighed like [__] half a
[__] whatever the [__] it was that
minute
unbelievable
deflategate and by the way can we stop
putting gate at the end of everything
that was funny in like the 1980s with
the Iran Contra and somebody called it
Iran gate and ever since then everything
is gate it's like [__] hacks come up
with a better Goddamn joke so there you
go everybody all you [__] [__] who
are on Twitter and you're trying to say
that uh
you know the Patriots a bunch of
cheaters I I see through everything that
you're saying you're saying you're sick
of losing to us but get used to it
because Tom Brady still has another
three four years left now can we get on
to talking about the Super Bowl
which is arguably the greatest [__]
matchup going oh you know I made a
[__] great point about the Patriots
Colts thing
um
did another [__] stain on the goddamn
table
sorry man I gotta clean this [__]
table this goddamn what's up this is
[__] gross
[__] gross anyways it's going to be a
great goddamn game
um I still Seattle should be favored but
every Mouse breathing [__] in Vegas is
going to see Brady and Belichick so they
put their money over there so then Vegas
has got to adjust the line to get money
on both sides of the ball it's the same
old-fucking story but um I actually like
that this whole stupid uh deflated
footballs things came out
um I think that's going to work to our
advantage
um
nah maybe if we played this Sunday I
think by next Sunday it's going to be
pretty much [__] over
[Music]
um
I'll be looking for some silly stupid
signs from dumb fans all painted in
green
you know the Seattle fans will have
signs talking about the Patriots like
the cheaters and uh no point will it
Dawn on them why they don't sound even
remotely as loud in a different Stadium
they'll blame it on the fact that half
the place is filled with [__]
Patriots fans well do the math he should
at least be half as loud as you are on
your Stadium which you're not going to
be
because down there in Arizona it's just
a regular old stadium so
so there you go that's my whole take on
that type of thing and uh here's the
deal if we play the [__] Super Bowl
in Seattle beats us and they do some
dumb [__] like [__] deflate the ball
a little bit you know and we lose by 38.
okay give me a [__] break
I will sit there and be like wow the
Seattle Seahawks just kicked their
[__] ass that's what I would say
but you know that's not how the [__]
world works is it when you get [__]
four 24 hours
um
24-hour uh sports channels it was a
[__] lead story on CNN
give me a [__] break so anyways what
do I think about the Super Bowl I have
no I I mean I think on paper the [__]
Seahawks win
I think defense wins championships as
they always say and they have the better
defense and a monster defense
um
I love their defense I think uh
and I think it's way easier to shut down
the Patriots offense than it is to beat
Seattle's defense
and I think our defense is good but it's
not as good as Seattle's and when I look
at it I just feel like that's going to
be the difference
we're not good at stopping the run and
they have Marshawn Lynch
and uh Russell Wilson is obviously
looking pretty human after the last game
but I mean maybe he just had a bad game
but uh that guy's mobile as hell
and so we're obviously as all teams
we're gonna have to have one guy just
sitting there babysitting him the entire
[__] game
but uh they don't have the greatest
receivers
I don't know
but I still you know we can't get any
pressure on the quarterback
I swear to God so I I don't know uh I
just think on paper we lose but for some
reason I have a good feeling for some
reason I think we're going to win that's
probably just me as a Patriots fan but
uh this is really a Super Bowl I have no
[__] idea
um I have no idea about but I got this
feeling that it's gonna be a classic
I really hope it is
um I don't want to see a boring one but
here's the thing I don't know if I'm
even gonna be able to see it live I
think I'll be live we'll do it live I
think I'm actually flying to New Zealand
when the [__] game is on
and it's a five hour flight
they better have some [__] TVs on
there
man I screwed up booking this tape this
[__]
tour when I did how the [__] did I know
the Pats were gonna be in this goddamn
Super Bowl
remember that when they lost to the
[__] Chiefs now everybody's acting
like they didn't [__]
say that they were done I was convinced
they were done
I thought uh
you know I just felt like it you know
we just kept getting rid of veterans
didn't want to pay their last contract
and we just were getting slowly weaker
by the season I totally bought into it
so I'm as surprised as anybody that were
there so that's it I won't talk anymore
about that [__] so anyways I'm over here
in Australia and uh today lo and behold
is uh Australia Day
I don't know why I don't know what it is
if it's their independence day I don't
know that
you know I don't know a [__] thing
about Australia I know they have a very
similar
um
history to the United States in that
you know they had some Englishmen come
over here right and then there was
people already here so that was a
problem
and they dealt with it in a way that uh
centuries later
you know
musicians and [__] with guilt would
write songs didn't they
uh where the river broke
right that time has come
you remember that guy he said the time
has come to save fair is fair
to pay the rent to pay our share and
then the only let's give it back wow wow
wow
give what back the [__] land
and then when you're going to displace
[__] nine million people how many
[__] people in this country
it's over
you know
it's a terrible thing that happened just
give them casinos like we did
and you get on with your lives
so anyways I have no idea what Australia
Day is
um I could probably look it up here for
you if you want to you already heard
room service you want to listen to me
[__] type here anyways let's say
basically they celebrate Australia
I I got to think that they could have
come up with a better [__] name than
Australia Day
hey it's USA day
you know it's not attached to anything
but whatever I gotta respect it
everybody gets a day off which is great
and on a Monday which is even better so
you get a three-day [__] weekend
and then everybody kind of boozes it up
we got out here to Perth you know what I
saw two [__] El Camino looking cars
that I I haven't seen like uh
I don't like I don't it wasn't made by
Chevrolet
but what was [__] hilarious
is that both people were [__] kind of
doing burnouts and driving like [__]
so it's nice to see that that made me
feel like I was home
oh like a guy with a ratty haircut
driving a [__] El Camino looking car
all right here we go uh Australia Day
is the official official the official
national day see that's how I read my
[__] brain is ahead of my goddamn
mouth Australia Day Australia Day is the
official national day of Australia uh
celebrated annually on the 26th of
January it marks the anniversary of the
1788 arrival of the First Fleet of
British ships at Port Jackson New South
Wales and raising of the flat the flag
of Great Britain at that site by
Governor Arthur Phillip by the way that
reference do you have a flag that's
um
Eddie Izard who was actually on my
flight
um and I want to say hello to him
because I'm a huge fan but I don't I
just felt like I was going to be bugging
him so I didn't he's actually over here
right now thank God not playing the same
city that I'm playing or I wouldn't have
sold any tickets
um in present-day Australia celebrations
reflect a diverse society and Landscape
of the nation nice
nice see how they wiggled their way out
of that
because I was just saying the indigenous
people here must not be thinking January
26 was the great [__] day in their
history so now they've kind of moved it
around it's kind of uh you know the
diverse society that we live in
you know we live indoors and uh you live
outdoors in the outback
or maybe you sit around playing a
[__] didgeridoo on the street corner
in Sydney
um
family events Reflections on Australian
history
Reflections on Australian history yeah
we probably shouldn't have killed all
those people uh officially official
Community I'm not I'm not judging you
guys you Aussie people okay we get the
same [__] history and worse imagine
if you did that and then you added
slavery
and then uh
then you let a select group of people
take over your food supply and turn it
into poison
right and then everybody gets addicted
and then years later you yell at the fat
people on a show called The Biggest
Loser
you know what they finally came out with
a [__] article talking about how
dangerous that show is uh me and Nia
used to watch that all the time and I
used to sit there saying they're gonna
[__] kill somebody somebody's gonna
die I don't work out this hard ever in
my [__] life
and uh
you know I'm not 400 pounds over [__]
weight but they were talking they did
this whole article on it
talking about people [__] up their
joints and having a really really bad
problems and
afterwards and putting the weight back
on and the diets that like basically the
amount of calories that they give them
is like
really dangerous
and all the [__] that you obviously knew
when you watched the [__] show but um
one of the funniest things was uh
something I can't even [__] remember
what the [__] was I just thinking of
oh Jesus Christ I mean this is the usual
me out of my mind and I'm beyond [__]
jet-lagged
um
oh I know they they said like really
over the top mean stuff
like you're not gonna see your
daughter's 12th birthday
and as mean as that is it's actually
true though
you can't walk around
some of the [__] they were doing there
was one guy I was actually jealous of
him
you know not that he was fat but just
fact I would love to have done what I
did every day he [__] had like three
Quarter Pounders with cheese
and like three large fries for lunch and
a giant Coke
you know
I know that you would feel like [__]
afterwards but just think of how awesome
that would be as you were consuming it
when you felt that Rush of salt and
sugar just sending your mood and
everything else
through the [__] roof that's one of
those things where you just start
rocking back and forth by the time you
get into the third one
and you're already drinking half a
gallon of soda you start like humming
songs that didn't even exist before you
know it's a very creative point during
that process before you just completely
crash out
um
but anyways how many minutes are we in
here
oh [__] 32 minutes okay let me let me
read a little bit of advertising who's
gonna know let me attempt
let me attempt to read here
you know what the time has come
to read the [__] advertisement
where the hell is it
live reads all right bam
okay
90 oh me undies me undies no more sweaty
balls hey you know what I'm actually
wearing a pair right now and I gotta
tell you they even work down under
down under my [__] balls there
I could be a personal trainer I mean I
couldn't the way I'm shaped right now
but I mean like I could do that [__]
job
I think
I know it'll be a fun job and then you
would stay in shape because you know no
one's going to go to a fat personal
trainer it'd be good uh good motivation
all right vegas.com unless you get some
[__]
did you see that that [__] dude in
the kayak that tipped over
help me I don't know what to do you
gotta see this thing if I can find it
some woman taped her [__] friend
water's filling up in the kayak if I
move it stinks I don't know what to do
this is an adult
can you imagine trying to personal train
that person I can't imagine the amount
of women out there
that are personal trainers right
to some [__] schlubby guy who [__]
[__] and moans like that that's got
to be extra [__] awful for him
you know
just to sit there dealing with I already
if he had some whiny female client I
would think a whiny dude would be even
worse
you know
I don't know anyways let me just move on
here vegas.com everybody 10 off
everything excluding air hotel packages
using my code Burr b-u-r-r uh vegas.com
is the way to book Vegas all right they
really do serve up Vegas from the inside
because unlike the other travel sites
they're from Vegas they live in Vegas
work in Vegas party in Vegas they give
you Insider tips on where to stay and
what to do when you get there vegas.com
comes propriety drop watch tool promises
the lowest rates on hotels drop watch
continues to monitor the prices even
after you book and notifies you of
changes to ensure that you get the best
deal book at the lower rate and they
will refund you the difference
um what book at the lower rate and they
what do you mean I'm booking at the
lower rate the difference of what the
higher price I was paying
you know Jesus vegas.com saves you money
on shows headliner shows comedy Penn and
Teller Ron White Carrot Top Cirque du
Soleil vegas.com offers more VIP bottle
service at top clubs oh we're in the
vocal VIP tickets
.com right now and when you book hotels
shows clubs pick anything on the site
that suits you enter my code Burr in the
promo box and check out uh check
check out and get an extra 10 off
everything but air hotel packages that's
vegas.com get bonus savings with my
secret code Burr I gotta tell you guys
if you want some Insider thing they kind
of alluded to it now they're getting
away from it but um
you can go out to Vegas and you can
drive like a [__] Lamborghini or a
Ferrari on a racetrack if you get off
the strip you also go out there and you
can shoot a [__] machine gun in the
desert okay
anybody can go and get some fake boobs
rubbed in their [__] face
okay as they drink a drink with the
[__] umbrella in it you know I'm not
saying don't do that
all right definitely do that and have a
good time but you know you should also
be talking to her
you know
Hey Porsche you know I shot a machine
gun today while riding in a Ferrari you
can do something like that
um all right my apologies for that awful
[__]
just awful everything in general the
content where the hell is it come on man
come back to me
time for the content and you won't show
it to me all right here we go
wait was there anything else I want to
talk about before I got into the emails
before I got right before I got to the
emails uh oh you know when I was on the
plane ride over
um
I actually uh you know I I watched that
movie Lucy that was a movie that I
wanted to see in um
in the theaters and just kind of came
and went I didn't hear the greatest
things about it I got to tell you for a
rental it's not bad
it's not a bad movie
you know you got that that big
pouty-lipped uh hotties
you know she's running around whatever
her [__] name is
Sebastian Bach what the [__] is her name
she's got one of those names except the
chick it's like the chick version of
Sebastian Bach
right
what is her name
Aniston
it's a really beautiful name
anyways she's in it and uh
they got some good bad guys they got
like some Asian mob guys those guys are
always cool you know what I mean they
[__] cut their finger off if they do
something bad for their boss I've always
liked that I've always liked the uh the
Italian mob thing I've always liked that
and uh the Asian mob guys you know what
I mean because the Asian mob guys always
combine like [__] not only could they
shoot a gun but then they always added
the martial arts [__] in there with
[__] knives and spinning stuff around
you know that's what I like about the
Asian mob before they whack you they
have the decency to put on like a show
like like murder Cirque du Soleil
right torture Cirque du Soleil whatever
the [__] it is I actually watched that
and then
you know I still had another like five
hours on the flight
and um
I I listened to uh Sergeant Pepper's
the whole [__] album which I hadn't
listened to in so long that is one of
the greatest
[__] albums of all time and this is
kind of this backlash by younger people
that try to say The Beatles are
overrated
um and all I'm going to say is I just
feel bad for you guys because I had
never heard of Jay Dilla until he died
and I follow Quest love on Twitter and
he did some sort of link and I kind of
got into that guy
and if you actually listen to Sergeant
Pepper with all the [__] that they got
going on in the background
crowd noises and all that and these
crazy sounds and all of that you almost
see like the
there's elements of what Jay Dilla was
doing on that album like [__] 40
years before it's absolutely [__]
amazing album but anyway so we were
flying right and as always I use all my
miles when I got a really long flight
like this
and uh so we were riding up front
like big shots and this woman
was up front these two women were
sitting next to each other in front of
them they had two little kids and then
there was another little kid and these
kids were running all all the [__] way
around and um
is there anything worse than seeing a
parent whose kid just doesn't even
listen to him
it's like seeing a coach that like lost
the locker room the kid kept getting up
the kid was getting up we were still
taken off like we were still we were
still ascending to our cruising altitude
and
um
this she's like she go hey I told you to
sit down he would just look at her nod
her head and then continue to [__]
run around
and um
I don't know she looked over me at one
point I just gave her this [__] look
like uh I don't know what it was I was
annoyed
because the kid kept you know running by
and then bumping into you and the kid
was old enough to not be cute anymore
you know
he was just old enough where I was
considering tripping him when he went by
he was like that age what is that age
like six
seven years old
not seven seven you can talk to him
it's like the four and under you don't
lay your hands on them between four and
six you trip them and then after that
age you just look at them like you set
them down like a person you're like dude
what the [__] wrong with you
all right is that good parenting
um
anyways uh all right let's get to the
[__] questions here for the week
where the hell are they
I'll tell you it's cool being at the
airport man now that I'm actually flying
and to all the [__] that I looked out
the window and I never [__]
understood
I'm actually seeing what Runway we're on
what taxiway we're on
and I'm figuring out why we're still
holding there you know it's pretty
[__] cool
because it was uh
horrible weather just gloomy in that
type of [__] so
um
[__]
the uh Tower head like all this traffic
lined up and we were just sitting there
and my wife's going like you know how
can I not leaving we're not leaving
and I'm looking out the window and I
think Ike was able to call it like when
when he was going to let us go
um
I don't know I can't wait to get back to
that I got six more lessons and then I
actually take my I have my check ride
and uh I can't [__] wait
I can't [__] that'll be a major [__]
accomplishment if I actually get that
thing I gotta be honest with you that I
brought my notebooks and all that [__]
to study
and um these [__] pre-tests on the
internet
and uh I don't know you got to get a 70
and my school tries to get you up to
like 90. and um I I'm all over the map
I'm 85.90 on some [__] and other stuff
I'm in the 60s but I'm no lower than the
60s so I figure this the next three
weeks as I'm out on the road I'll just
try to do an hour and a half every
[__] day
um anyway so probably bored the [__] out
of you but I don't care all right
be the match everybody
uh Billy MD I'm a 45 year old female
whose son survived from a rare form of
bone marrow cancer because of
bethematch.org bethematch.org was
something that I I uh mentioned joining
um a couple podcasts ago in case you
weren't listening so anyways I was
driving to work and listening to your
podcast and when you mentioned this I
almost started screaming for joy uh we
you're the first woman who ever listened
to my podcast who considered screaming
for Joy unless I was saying well that's
the podcast for this week then they're
usually like oh thank God it's over
um we were told that he would have a
very hard time qualifying to be a donor
because of
certain factors you mean getting a donor
um very hard time yeah
to be a donor I think you mean qualify
getting a qual a match I should say
anyways we stayed positive and after a
year and a half a donor match was found
the match was a young man in his late
20s who had heard about be the match
and decided to enter
decided to register on a whim thank you
so much for mentioning it on the podcast
my husband and I often question why
programs like this aren't mentioned in
bigger forums uh be it 60 Minutes or the
State of the Union Address I don't know
anyone who wouldn't help someone's save
someone's life if they could the donor
or as we refer to him as Superman had
heard about this from a friend at a
dinner party attending that dinner party
in turn saved my son's life which means
that you can be part of Saving someone's
life too just by having mentioned it
uh I'm welling up just writing this
email and I know your listeners are
usually writing in about psycho women
and sports but if you happen if you do
happen to read this I just want you to
know that it means the world to us Jesus
is too [__] nice for me to read
um too many comments here uh to
reiterate what you mentioned on the
podcast the test is literally just
swapping I think swabbing your cheek
with a Q-tip
not swapping a cheek that would be uh
some Face-Off [__] uh
with the Q-tip they send you and putting
it in a mailbox if you happen to match
with someone in the registry they
contact you and you have the option of
saving someone's life [__] this I'm
doing this
I gotta do this Jesus Christ uh be the
match.org everybody how about you do
that
why don't you guys go out and do that
thing and then the next time your spouse
your girlfriend or your boyfriend gives
you [__] like what have you been doing
all day what have I been doing saving
[__] lives lady
or buddy whatever women say to that guys
you [__] [__] all right got drunk
said some things
wow got drunk said some things did I
write this uh dear bill I am what many
people have called a habitual line
Crosser ah the classic Charlie Murphy
line
from the Rick James
sketch uh I am a habitual line Crosser
when I drink last night I was out with
some co-workers and my boss oh no at a
brewery Festival oh Jesus
all right what are you guys guessing
here
um
probably told his boss he didn't know
what he was doing
and if his boss was female he probably
made a pass at her
what are you guys going with did he say
something dumb or did he grab somebody's
ass
anyways I ended up getting [__] I
ended up getting [__] rocked and told
my boss to her face oh my God she's a
female here we go
I am willing to lose my job to sleep
with you
that's actually kind of funny
he said she laughed and blushed at the
Bold statement and proceeded to leave
almost directly after this oh no
oh you said it to the wrong person
oh you said it to the wrong person I'm
writing this to you on Sunday morning
and have to report
to the old [__] clock puncher
tomorrow I have no shame addressing
sexual tension with the woman but my
boss [__] me my plan is to just carry
on like it never happened because
honestly I don't care
and see
how she responds with either a not
addressing it and keeping me employed B
filing sexual harassment losing my job
and sleeping with me and he writes yeah
see filing sexual harassment losing my
job and not sleeping with me boo
uh letting me keep my job and sleeping
with me [__] yeah what's your what's
your take on all of this
um
I don't have a take on it because you
have to give a [__]
and you don't
you're one of those guys I have no
problem
I have no shame addressing sexual
tension
um
I love the sexual tension what your
sexual attention it doesn't seem like
she had any
kind of just looking at this from your
own perspective
um you have all the makings of a
high-ranking CEO and of a corporation
because you you don't give a [__] you
have no guilt whatsoever you've already
weighed out all the options you just hey
I get away with it I either do or I
don't you've completely emotionally not
even attached to this thing
um
you're a dangerous human being I hope
you don't get a uh I hope you're not in
charge of the [__] water supply
all right relationship advice yo Billy
[__] tits
first off just want to say and right now
that guy's like what the [__] man that's
[__] dude think about it right now
you don't have any guilt whatsoever you
don't give a [__]
you're not looking like oh man I got a
drinking problem I uh you know
I gotta change my life you know if I'm
going to get anywhere in life you
completely don't even give a [__] and
then you turn yourself into like this
[__] hero hey I got no problem
addressing sexual attention hey you know
who I am you know I am
somebody's got to say it's going to be
me
whatever man good for you I hope you
banger
all right it's time for some more
advertising I actually forgot to read
these things so I just had to [__]
read these and then drop them and so
sorry for the abrupt
um going for me babbling to talking
about the [__] advertising all right
uh relationship advice yo Billy [__]
tits first off just want to say huge fan
of your stand-up podcast
all right so I am 21 years old and in
the military living in England I just
got here two months ago and have a
girlfriend back home in the states who
I've been with for about a year and a
half and you've already met someone who
wants to ban you over there because you
got an accent and a military haircut and
you've been doing pull-ups and you're in
the primary life right that's what I'm
guessing she's a great girl tall
brunette has a [__] rocking body oh
Jesus and it's a sweetheart with a good
family ah good Lord dude if all of that
is true
I would rub one out in England for a
while
um I feel like I hit the jackpot and we
are working on getting her over here
uh which would mean we would have to be
married
I want to do it but at the same time
whenever we talk about it I get nervous
as [__] and this weird feeling in my gut
holding me back I don't know if that's
normal cold feet or what I feel like if
I dumped her
I'd be making a huge mistake but at the
same time I don't want to get married
and wake up two years from now Angry
that I wasn't Single Living overseas and
could have had the time of my life what
would you do in my situation she's the
mother of my kids
material
what
but not sure if we're too young
oh she's the mother of my kids material
but not sure if we're too young thanks
and go [__] yourself
um
I don't know how old you are you sound
like you're young I would address this
with her
I don't know is that bad advice
I think every guy [__] has cold feet
and freaks the [__] out
and it's just like Jesus Christ what the
[__] am I doing
what the [__] am I doing because women
get married it's just like there's such
an advantage to it
you know the way the divorce laws are
set up like they're they're for the most
part they're not going to lose unless
they're making more money and then they
got to be nervous I would think
but also I think just in general they're
they're they believe in that romance
stuff and all that [__]
what would you do
um
I don't know man
that's a [__] rough one
I almost said that's a rough one you
know
do you love her
you know what I mean if you love her and
you don't want a loser I gotta tell you
um
you won't regret marrying her
all right
occasionally you'll be pissed that you
didn't Crush all that ass over there and
you're going to the bathroom and you'll
rub one out and the second you rub one
out you're gonna be like uh you know I
made the right [__] choice
all right
I don't know are you 21 years old though
do you know I got to get married at 21.
here's the deal
just tell you want to be with her you're
not ready to get married you're only 21
years old that's what I would do
see I don't want to be married yet I'm
only 21. I want to experience my 20s a
little bit
what do you mean [__] somebody else yeah
no
dude you're only 21 years old okay if
this [__] woman already wants to get
married I mean I think it's normal to 21
to [__] not want to get married
just say look Let's Get Married around
like 26.
what is the rush let's be single and
[__] enjoy ourselves but like be
together whatever I would go down that
road
um
ah Jesus you know sometimes you guys ask
me these life-changing [__] questions
and I gotta try to weigh all options
here
I don't want you to get rid of the love
of your life and I also don't want to
[__] have you locked down to 21.
it's going to come down to you they're
[__] private you're gonna have to
figure this one out
um
but uh yeah I would I would start with
that see if you can
oh I see to get her over there you'd
have to [__] marry her
dude that's not a reason to marry her
I would do the long-distance
relationship thing
um
I don't know what the [__] I would do
all right sorry I did my best if anybody
has any advice for this kid just [__]
write in next week and I'll you know if
it makes sense I'll read it all right
annoying father-in-law dear Bill I'm a
pretty well-rounded guy
all right let's all right let's [__]
run out of the game this guy's patting
himself on the back I'm not a complete
stiff but I'm also not a flake
but wait a minute dude those are both
bad things
you know
I'm not a jerk but I'm also not an
[__]
I'm not a complete stiff but also not a
flake
ah what that doesn't make any [__]
sense to him anyways I have my [__] in
order when you work hard to have your
life together the last thing you want is
someone telling you stuff you don't need
to hear about when you're supposed to be
doing
or what you're supposed to be doing with
your life and money
my father-in-law is this person in my
life all he cares about is the market
stocks bonds mutual funds IRAs he
actually wrote bongs instead of bonds
all he talks about is watching his money
grow and now I should be saving
everything so I can live rich when I'm
older the thing is I do save
aggressively I'm doing just fine
recently I booked a trip to Greece to
surprise my wife for our third wedding
anniversary on our first date she said
she always wanted to go to Greece I told
her she'd get there within five years
that was just under five years ago look
at you you're a man of your word it
seems like I can't claim through clutch
here her father on the other hand said
it was not the right time because of the
exchange rate safety of traveling abroad
and anything else he could throw in
there how do I respond to him do I laugh
it off and just wait
until he talks [__] again and again and
live with it would I put him pull him
aside and let him know I don't want to
hear his [__] anymore thanks I would do
both I would experimenting with laughing
It Off
at first and if he keeps coming at you
at some point you just gotta take him
aside
you know
and just be like listen
um I would actually talk to you Ma to uh
your wife about it first just to tell
her that you're gonna do it just in case
he comes at her with his [__] story
of like I was just trying to help it he
he just browbeated me
I would just say
you just say to your wife like listen I
know your father means well but uh
you know he's always talked to me about
my finances our finances and that type
of thing all right I know he's very
smart with money and that type of thing
but I also feel like I'm smart with
money in my own way
all right and uh I've saved my money and
we can afford this and we're young and
you're beautiful and you want to go to
Greece and I'm taking you because I love
you all right but I got to be honest
with you if your dad keeps opening his
Yap I'm gonna [__] shove a dinner
roll in it are we cool all right
what are we watching tonight
Real Housewives Are we going to watch a
little Sports whose night is it there
you go and then you're out
but at some point yeah you got to sit
down if you do have an uh an annoying
person like that in your life you really
do you gotta sit down with them
and you have to do it uh I do it in our
restaurant take them out to lunch
you know
so there's no option for any screaming
and yelling
and um
just lay it on the line
you just got to say to them like listen
you know I love your daughter more than
anything in the world and you have to
know that I'm going to take care of her
all right and then it'll be oh right
right off the bat you catch him off
guard because he knows it's a [__]
deep conversation he wasn't ready for it
you're ready
all right and just say listen
um I know you're concerned about her
well-being
of course you are you're a great dad
all right
but
I am saving money
and we are going to be fine I just do it
a little bit different than you your
daughter has always wanted to go to
Greece
and I would rather take her now in the
prime of her life then bring her over
there
when we're both you know walking around
with dentures
and Keynes okay
I want her to enjoy this before we have
kids and blah blah blah blah blah this
is what I'd like to do and I need you to
respect that
and I appreciate your comments about
our finances but I would but I would
I don't uh how do you say this part I
would just say listen I will come to you
because I know you know what you're
doing but if I if I am having a problem
financially which I am not
but if I am you are the first person I
will come to with advice
okay until then I don't want to hear
another [__] word
I'm gonna [__] do it smooth it out
that's basically what you do all right
so that's the podcast for this week
everybody
um I got my first show tomorrow night
um here in Perth
I'm really looking forward to it man
um
I'm gonna put my hour together out here
and looking forward to all the people
that I'm going to see uh and Comics that
I'm going to meet and that type of [__]
and uh
it's gonna be insane it's already been
saying going through Australia and into
New Zealand but when I go into Southeast
Asia
um experience in those cultures it's
just going to be unreal like in China
you had this great interview
um
with the guy for the the Hong Kong gig
and he was mentioning how Hong Kong you
know that they're they're basically
their own deal they have their own
Constitution and [__]
but in mainland China as he called it
like do you know he said recently the
they they banned
puns they banned puns in word play in
the media which I know everybody else is
probably gonna laugh like all that silly
you can't make a pun but you know humor
is a great way to take the piss out of
the [__]
people that are in power
um
and it's a clever way to do it where you
can't quite get busted for it
and unless you get a psycho which maybe
they do but whatever but it's a way to
kind of make your point and stay out of
jail
and start a movement or whatever so they
banned that type of thing and I guess
the comedians in China are pushing the
boundaries
of what is allowed on stage and what is
amazing to me over there is that in
China the stand-ups over there that art
form
which I think eventually it will go
Global it's really weird that that art
form has not the fact that music you
know acting and all these uh film all
the pictures painting all the other Arts
are worldwide but stand up
one of the great Arts
I feel that there is is not worldwide
and it's like brand new essentially in
China and what's so fascinating mainland
China what's so fascinating to me is
that they are actually pre-lenny Bruce
over there
you know what I mean
like I look at these other places where
they can actually talk and I'm like it's
exciting to me because it's like all
right they're going to have their
Richard Pryor they're gonna have their
George Carlin their Sam Kinison or
whatever
and um
you know these these guys are are
actually in China are like they're
waiting for their Lenny Bruce to come
along
which is pretty amazing to me and um I
also can't imagine living in that type
of Oppression
how that would affect the comedy
um
on just like a whole other level
like just listening to like Richard
Pryor
and
what he ended up talking about because
of what he went through
I can't imagine over there
I know it's just like a different thing
like there's that whole [__]
experience living in a [__] country
with his like
what is that three to four billion
[__] people or something like that or
a billion people they got over there I
just can't imagine
how you would try to stand out over
there and then you get this oppressive
[__] thing where people gotta stand
in front of tanks and [__] I know that
was like 25 years ago but
um I don't know
um I think it's gonna be really
interesting too I'm hoping that some
comics when I go to Hong Kong some
Chinese Comics will come out and I'll
get to talk to them
and find out about that because the guy
was actually going would you actually do
a gig
on Main in mainland China and I was like
no
I wouldn't
because I don't know how to [__] I've
been a free man
so I wouldn't know how to rein that in I
mean I've done corporate gigs and tried
to tone it down but I wouldn't trust
myself to not blurt out something that
would then and I'd end up
God knows what
haven't have somebody call a [__]
embassy over a [__] I mean I don't I
couldn't handle that because the guy was
going do you have any advice for those
kids over there and I was like no I
don't because I
I would had a a privileged stand-up
career where all those walls were
already broken down I actually said well
I would rather I would like to talk to
him
you know and hear what they're going
through but uh
hopefully you know things open up over
there because I really don't think that
any government if you [__] oppress
the people it's just it's like
this it can only last for so [__]
long before people have had it
um
so hopefully uh you know Jesus Christ I
mean you need government and you need
[__] rules and that type of [__] but
you don't got to be taking it to that
level
Banning puns and [__] wordplay give
me a break anyway so that's the type of
[__] I'm going to be encountering here
on this trip uh like I said I'm gonna
try to watch the Super Bowl I'll figure
out when the [__] it is I actually left
and I forgot to tape it
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast another NFL
Edition and this week we will be talking
about its championship week everybody
it's championship and then there were
four
and then there's four weeks left Paul
what happened every year
uh dude it's sad the fact that there's
only a few games left is [__] sad
it's over
um like so fast Paul but
but I'll tell you what I am I might have
had a good regular season but boy
am I I mean with the points with the
points in the playoffs I am hurting Bill
you're definitely having a better
playoff run than me I mean my New York
football Giants
that's a that's a that's a that's
I mean I am too I took the Giants too
uh I had the Bengals I had the 49ers
I don't even know if they covered 49ers
cover they covered right
um
mush I literally watched the damn game
dude just coming in just breaking their
hearts Buffalo they're like this is yeah
we're a team of Destiny the whole
country's rooting for us because of that
poor kid
football Gods say no again this year
Paul but you got to start to wonder
what happened
in the Buffalo Rochester area that they
just
I mean they had all the pieces
and every year Paul to Pieces they just
they just they like the snow falling
they fall in the ground
Bengals came in there like assassins
dude and you know what's crazy and I I
tweeted something and at the exact same
time I tweeted it the hilarious Joe list
tweeted it and then we texted with each
other going it blew my mind Tony Romo in
the second quarter of the game and it
was the only time in my life because I'm
a Tony Romo guy everybody a lot of
people talk I like Tony Romo but this
was the first game where I'm going what
is he he said in the second quarter and
I'm going did anybody hear this he goes
well you know Buffalo they really need
to score here if there's any hope and he
said that and I go dude any hope I go
it's a seven point game in the second
quarter so then I tweeted it and then I
saw Joe list and he goes yeah it blew my
mind but he was right now he saw he saw
that Buffalo was finished early and he
knew that they couldn't stop it
um but an announcer shouldn't and a
national broadcast in the second quarter
goes out dude if they want any hope I
had one solid quarterback coach instead
of 47 during his tenure with the Cowboys
now everybody's jumping all over Zach
Prescott dude when your team doesn't win
for 30 [__] years at some point you
got to look at the front office and stop
blaming your quarterbacks and running
them out of town oh that's a hot take
Paul
yeah that's right up on ESPN the banner
yeah what about uh we gotta do that
segment Paul we got to do the uh the New
York Post trying to guess the headlines
oh so this is so this is going to be a
new thing that me and Bill talked about
it's going to be on the show and we
decided to do it with the New York Post
because I don't care how you feel about
politics or anything the New York daily
news does not do these as good as the
post but the post will always come up
with one of those clever after a game
it'll be like for example like not so
giant and then it'll be like the Giants
losing or some [__] like that so me and
Bill when they were talking about uh
they were talking about how many people
are smoking pot you know and you can
smell it everywhere in New York uh
remind
in one hour
um so
that said uh
Eureka
r-e-e-k Eureka
uh something like that the city that
that always reeks
and then they had a couple of go I
forget what they were they had like
[__] nine jokes on two pages
all about that uh
um
how New York smells like doobie doobie
doo yeah reference and a weed reference
so we're gonna start trying to guess the
New York see if the games go the way
that we want
we got the Bengals and Chiefs and we got
the Philadelphia Eagles and the 49ers we
already came up with one you came up
with one
well let's do our picks first okay okay
we'll do our we'll do our picks first
um
so look I I would I actually think I'm
right with both of these now okay and I
know it's only two but I think I'm right
but we got Andrew we got the live lines
I like you we gotta get the live lines
here
now to win the game to win the game I
have you want me to do my picks and then
you do your picks oh I would love to
hear your pics the whole world will be
your picks Paul okay
I like Cincinnati and Philadelphia to
win the game and be in the Super Bowl
but Andrew I need the live numbers now
because I said if it's over seven I
would take the Niners so what is the
what is that line
the Niners are getting two and a half
okay Niners are getting two and a half I
love Philadelphia in that game
especially in
what's that I love the Eagles
the Eagles at home it's a problem
the Eagles at home after what they you
know after what they did to the Giants
approved Jalen hurts is a healthy I love
that and I I'm rooting for the Niners I
think yeah coach Naughton and the thing
going I know what the [__] I'm doing I
know what the [__] I was doing too if I
had Jalen hurts by the way let's talk
about that for a second and this is not
sour grapes from a Giants fan I promise
one of the worst things that I've ever
saw any coach do is when that dude
looked in the camera and went
dude that was that was an upper dick at
yank down to his [__] eyeballs dude
that was a fan in the upper deck it's at
the bus stop that gets hit in the side
of the head with an ice ball yo that was
a fan in the upper deck that was a fan
I've never seen a coach go dude that was
one of the worst douchiest things oh who
would ever say I know what the [__] I'm
doing that's how morons think
I know what the [__] I'm doing it's just
like nobody knows what the [__] I'm
doing you're having a good day
oh my God you imagine Bill Parcells or
Bill Belichick ever looking in the
camera going dude
and Jalen hurts the amount of improv on
every [__] play where he did the
whatever the play is is out the [__]
window and then he makes something
happen and then this [__] snowball
throwing jerk off his own I don't know
what the [__] I'm doing
he likes the camera this coach too he
loves to he loves the camera no dude
they were doing the 360 shot around the
guy like every [__] play I know I
know
it's it's bad enough when they do with
the players you know Paul the the game
is passed us by we're just two old guys
I I missed the old stoic coach that just
sits there remember Joe Torrey you would
never know anything he didn't smile
until you won the World Series
and even then it was a half a smile
there were two types of coaches when I
was coming up there were the Joe Torres
who were stoic and didn't say much and
then there were The Bill Parcells who
didn't recognize it and they were just
more of like the Bobby Knights now you
got fans you got fans coaching you got
guys talking and Instagram influencer it
started with you got you called it bill
it started with Rex Ryan Rex Ryan was
the first guy to be like we're gonna go
down there and we're gonna [__] we're
the New York Jets Gary Glanville
that was always the guy like sort of
popping off I just never saw a guy play
to the [__] camera and like
um look there's always been like
personalities like that but now it's
just so like I mean he's trying to get
like a sneaker deal he's trying to get
like a [__] aftershave lotion [__]
uh commercial he's trying he's trying to
be a spokesperson for Aqua Velva take it
away from George Brett whatever who
gives a [__] I can tell you this though
that guy's got a great [__] team he
does they're gonna they're gonna beat
the same if they beat the San Francisco
49ers I think it's gonna be uh not so
party
Eagles soared to the Super Bowl
yeah yeah yeah not so Purdy
um
and then I think if the party is ugly
yeah yeah and if the Eagles if the
Eagles pull it off it'll be like
uh I mean I'm sorry if the Niners pull
it off like Niners ground
Purdy grounds Birds there's not
something along with the flight of a
bird they can't live off party what
like 49ers sitting party as Eagles fall
[Laughter]
The Writer's room
what about this one Purdy grounds the
birdie
[Laughter]
dude Purdy grounds the birdie and then
you just see an eagle sitting on a
[__] yeah or something like that
um already grounds the birdies party
grounds the birdies
um all right and then one ever
on the New York Post was when Clemens
said he was retiring
and they had a big send-off with the
Yankees and then he signed with Houston
and the title said what an astro
I thought
that's pretty good it was like they
called him an [__] in a clean way no
the post the post
um all right now so we I like the eagles
with the uh by by three and then there's
no way there's no way jokes for some
reason I guess the young kids are
calling him Joe shiesty have you heard
that no oh so anyway but Joe burrow is
gonna go into Arrowhead
and he's gonna beat the one-legged
limping Mahomes I think he would beat
him even if he wasn't hurt I think
they're really good dude
what's that one
Chiefs are getting one Chiefs are
getting one which means it's a pickum
it's a pickle
I think burrow gets back there he's got
the running game he's got the [__] uh
you know Jamar chase that wide receiver
he's got T Higgins he's got some good
players it's been running the ball he's
got a great McPherson's a great I think
McPherson's a great kicker I'm gonna
take the I'm gonna take Cincinnati to
win that game got anything he knows
protecting his backside sorry
um I gotta tell you Paul this game
scares me
I don't think that either team spanks
the other team I think one is the
perfect number I only think Casey is is
getting one because Mahomes is allegedly
hurt I've seen that guy get hurt in
games and come back and win he did it
with against the Cleveland Browns I
don't think that he's going to be
limping around
um
I think the BTK killer that [__]
coach out there Andy Reid dead ringer
for the big TK killer
yeah
you know those guys have been there
before they got Travis Kelsey I don't
know about this Paul I think this is a
classic Trap game where they just beat
the bills
trap as far as being a better that you
just think because it just seems like oh
yeah Joe Pearl just doesn't lose in the
playoffs he's got the thing going you
know he was just too young to win the
Super Bowl that one time
oh this is a tough one to pull off
this is a tough one I'm actually gonna
go KC oh okay
it's gonna hurt me because I love Joe
burrow and I love the Bengals but I just
feel like uh everybody's gonna think the
Bengals everybody's gonna be like
[__] uh uh the forward lateral guy
there
is going to be Patrick Mahomes is going
to be hurt
blah blah blah they're going to put a
bunch of money on it I think the line's
gonna move Paul I think you're gonna get
more than one point you might get a
point and a half or two come Sunday and
uh it's gonna be a foregone conclusion
just one of those [__] games and then
Chiefs are gonna come out and Vegas is
going to clean up
if Mahomes does one of those laterals
and they go oh he got one leg he's
unbelievable what's gonna happen
anything that does it's just like it
sounds like wrestling like somebody just
ran out of the [__] locker room
and it goes Pat Patterson
um all right so if the Chiefs win
yep
oh I had it uh what Mahomes hobbles into
the Super Bowl Chiefs hobble into this
battle uh Patrick Mahomes
uh
gives Cool Joe the Deep Freeze
Patrick mcmones
loses something about they're gonna
figure out how to make it yeah yeah same
talk about how he was hurt
and we uh I'm trying to think of if
they're gonna use the the last name
burro too Burrows his way into the
barrels his way something that'll be it
yeah yeah back in the day they would
have made like an Indian reference
Chiefs get massacred
back
the hatchet yeah something like that
um
wait a minute what's his name oh but
here's the thing here's the thing we're
forgetting Jamar Chase and Joe Mixon are
big parts so so like burrow chases the
the Chiefs as something there's gonna be
something like that oh let me think of
one oh burrow the Right Mix
oh the right Chaser oh my God wait a
minute Joe Mixon I like that one yeah
yeah the right uh
the Right Mix uh [__] there's two jokes
he's not as easy as you think
uh
especially when the two of us put our
heads together so you're so you're
taking you're taking the Chiefs to to
beat him I'm rooting for the Bengals but
I just got this feeling man I got this
feeling bam bump sorry
um
I just think the Chase has been there
they got a great [__] coach I don't
think my homes is going to be as hurt
wink wink nudge nudge you know
if he is really hurt magically he won't
feel the pain on Sunday you know how it
is Paul yeah that's the question Paul
can you go and there's only one answer
yes
yes I can put me in coach they're gonna
get him in there
they're gonna needle them up yeah
they're gonna throw a needle in his leg
his neck leg's gonna be [__] numb and
he's gonna play
yeah
hey they gave the guy 400 million
dollars he's playing he's [__]
what 400 million dollars do you want 400
million dollars gets you in Kansas City
that gets you can't Kansas City
hey uh yeah by the whole city and every
barber joined in it for 400 million
dollars your money goes a long
[__] way out there man
if if Andy Branson get yourself a
houseboat
if if if Andy Reed makes a good coaching
move and they go
like if he challenges something Andy
reads it right
or reads it right something like that
um at it twice right
reason right
dude we have such a couple of summer
school kids huh
um
all right so Paul burnsey has the
Cincinnati Bengals lion one
yeah Oh Billy fractal took Casey getting
one and then we got uh we both took the
Eagles
we both took the Eagles uh on like you
said with the other with the Chiefs and
the and the Bengals I'm rooting for the
Niners I'm rooting for the Niners but I
I have to be uh I have to I saw what I
saw and even though the coach did that
and even though they beat my team uh I I
they're a better team so Eagles coach I
would love to have a beer with that guy
absolutely but I'll tell you this right
now no one knows what the [__] they're
doing to that level
for that level to sit there and not at
the [__] camera it's like dude you're
winning a playoff game thousands upon
thousands of coaches have done that
yeah and went any further so like I
don't know and plus like I said
[__] broken record here that to see
what Jalen hurts was doing
you know what I mean it's like [__]
I can't say LT but back in the day when
LT was running around Bill Parcells you
know
not going to take anything away from
that guy but he literally had a Marvel
superhero
yeah on the Phil Jackson
yeah okay Phil Jackson's got more rings
than red Arabic he also had Superman and
Superman's son to build this [__]
team around like okay Jesus Christ did
you win yeah and the hole and Jack
yeah the whole Mountain that could talk
um
you know what I liked siriani before the
nod of the head because they asked him
they go hey did you watch the Giants did
you watch the Giants and the Minnesota
game and he goes yeah I gotta had all
the coaches in the room and you know
what for some reason we just decided to
get some bad pizza or something he goes
we got Pizza Hut stuffed crust pizza and
we just sat down and watched it and ate
it and I was like all right this guy's
this guy's like you know even though
it's terrible he knew and then when I
saw the head nod and then the you don't
think I know what the [__] I'm doing I
was like all right I'm done I'm done
um but all right so we both like that we
both like the eagles and Bill's gonna
take the Chiefs I'm gonna take uh Joe
burrow getting one and there you go you
know what um what the [__] you're doing
that because I because we know what the
[__] we're
he literally looked like some jerk off
with End Zone seats nodding into the
camera excited that he was on TV and
this is like a professional head
football coach I really think that that
was a a moment in NFL history where now
all the young coaches that saw it are
now going to start doing that [__] and
now we're gonna have to deal with like
the team they're gonna they have to have
a split screen when the team scores the
touchdown to watch the player doing his
dance and the head coach like what he's
doing
I I just like I don't know Paul I'm
telling you dude this is this is like a
we are living in an unprecedented
ignorant time
it is because all of these people in all
of these cameras and all these ways to
put your [__] opinions out there I
mean look at us Paul okay now like we're
not part of the problem but
um the way that ignorance is being like
like lofted up and something to Aspire
to and if I hear one more [__] say I
like this guy because he reminds me of
me I just want to be like have you done
any
introspective work on yourself
whatsoever
somebody had that joke like I like the
president he sounds like me he's like I
don't want the president to like me no I
want him to be way smarter yeah yeah
yeah
he's a regular guy
yeah yeah even [__] like us he
dude coaches used to be
coaches used to look like football
coaches the way baseball managers used
to now baseball managers are jacked and
thin I remember stump Merrill his name
was stump and he looked like a stump I
don't know if he's alive if he's alive
you know if he's not rest his soul he
came out to the Yankees he waddled out
to the mound everyone would go stump he
had a big belly he looked like a
baseball manager Don Zimmer rest his
soul looked like a baseball manager
football coach I'd give it to Andy Reed
Bill Parcells uh who was who was it a
Chuck not Chuck Noll Chuck Noble who's
the Eagles guy the Eagles won
oh uh uh dick for a meal no the other
one uh he had a oh oh Ryan buddy Ryan
Rex's dad
buddy Ryan buddy Ryan looked like those
guys look oh so does this brother Hank
Schram well his brother actually looks
like a roadie for the Allman Brothers
though yeah Hank Schram Hank Schram was
like a an In-Shape out of shape guy if
that makes sense he was like a put
together at a shape guy with the red
jacket Teamster body
yeah it talked like he was selling
watches he was he was like he just he
would always go over to the ref and like
have like really fast conversations yeah
yeah he talked like a used car salesman
yeah that you kind of liked yeah come on
that thing runs it runs great just kept
telling you yeah
yeah
Lombardi dude look at Lombardi Lombardi
not not the greatest to shape but you
were like this guy knows what he's what
the hell's going on out here that's that
nobody packed yeah now they showed that
one guy doing yoga the [__] coach of
the Chargers was like doing yoga with
his back it's just like I I don't like
it hey look dude I mean I don't want to
die either so these guys being in shape
doesn't bug me it's like I'm telling you
dude
that that [__] thing was that was a
shift
yeah shift yeah it was like When Donald
Trump was running for president and the
Press was accusing him of [__] and he
just said hey you know you're probably
right and they had no follow-up he
exposed them like you guys are a paper
tiger
there's nothing behind this like you
want me to Bow back down and then
[__] no I'm not leaving this election
and I'm admitting to what you're
accusing me of what do you got and they
had [__] nothing now did you see that
[__] Joe Budden did you see that Joe
Biden clip no the new one
from him way back in the day dude he's
going off going like I you know I I was
in the bottom third in my half of my
class and went up to the bot out of the
top third like the math didn't even work
out on it and I I have I have two
degrees in this blah blah blah blah all
of this [__] it was all [__] yeah
yeah and you saw him dude he was just
making up [__] back when his mind was
sharp that guy could make up [__]
lies on the Fly about how great it was
and that's the kind of [__] dude when I
was a kid if that ever came out you had
to [__]
you had to bow out
in shame you know changed it
Bill Clinton
yeah Bill Clinton
when Paul Bill Clinton's horse came out
and said he did this and he did all that
and he was just like I had a couple of
you know yeah fidelities but I ain't
leaving oh slick Willie yeah and I think
there with that [__]
Jesus Christ like you know Al Gore was
like Pinocchio middle age
it was like
sorry
dude I love uh did you see Dana did you
see Dana carvey's summer school George W
bush did you did you see Dana carvey's
Al Gore
he goes Dana Dana carvey's Al Gore he
goes he's like really like a feminate
and he goes it is getting hot
dude it's so [__] great
um
oh my god dude you know what that that
Arkansas twang makes you get away with
stuff dude it makes you if he sounded
like if he sounded like Trump he
wouldn't get away with it as much
what Bill Clinton was from Arkansas
where was Al Gore from yeah uh I don't
that's a good question Carolinas or
something like that it's got to be
oh
like I worked the soil I was I was
touching it you just said all stupid
[__] and he's staring and I'm like
why is this wooden puppet talking to me
about farming
um that guy really had the Charisma of
like a [__] door
Washington DC he's from DC
he was like What if an inanimate object
could talk this meant dude they've had
some bad ones like they've had some bad
people just bombing but then if you have
too much energy then you're [__]
that one guy
remember that guy oh uh Howard Dean
we gotta go to Minneapolis look at it
right there that was great and then he
was going huh
and they were dude they yanked him right
when that happened it was a wrap
and now it is it wouldn't even matter
it'd just be a meme and he would roll
with it and they would bring him on
stage to that sound
let's Battle Cry and there'd be a
million mouth breathing morons going
it's over Paul
it's over just enjoy yourself before we
fall into the ocean all right football
weekend everybody
um all right we're gonna do a uh we are
gonna do a one-game parlay for the AFC
Championship game versus the Chiefs and
the Bengals
um
this year
just won every round we have to knock
them out listen we're gonna do it this
week we're gonna do it this week and
we're gonna do it with the Super Bowl
because I know what the [__] I'm doing
and then we're gonna look at the camera
and go with our [__] dumb hats over
our eyes okay oh it looked like I had
his mother so
Mom I don't want to wear it
all right so you get uh pull it over
your ears it's snowing a couple prop
options uh I'll just I'll read a few out
you got Patrick Mahomes over under 285
passing yards
uh over under 15 rushing yards
I mean now that might just be a fun
under right there if you don't think
he's going to be able to move at all
um
but it's gonna do it
no but here's a deal if God forbid it's
like everything's on the line and he's
got open field in front of him and he
does it and everybody goes nuts and then
they go on one leg gets a first down I
don't even want to [__] let's play
Hurt at that position like that ever
before
um plus one passing yards plus two
passing passing touchdowns plus you
appreciate what you just saw that one
leg camper
yeah oh yeah I haven't seen somebody
sacrifice their body since John Elway
did the helicopter in the Super Bowl you
know all that [__] all right because
they actually gave credit that somebody
else did it you have to act like no one
has ever done it ever
all right all right
um
what's the Joe burrow passing situation
over under 275 yards uh anytime
touchdown that so that'd be rushing one
plus touchdown two plus touchdown
passing I think under on either one of
those I take the under on either one of
those so under 275 passing yards yeah
under under 275 passing yards for
Borough I agree
uh TouchDown for burrow
no I was saying for uh Patrick Mahomes I
do it with either one of them I just
don't see this game like they're gonna
be like [__] throwing 50-yard tons
into the unders what's the under from
the home passing yards what's the under
from a home's passing yards 285. I'll
take I like that under
so 285 for my homes 275 for Borough
no no we don't have to do both let's can
we I'm just saying that just a group yo
let's we'll you know
what do you think Bill which one do you
think is on more under Borough going 275
or my home's going 285.
I like my homes under even though I'm
betting the Chiefs I just think I just
think this is going to be one of
them yeah that's a lot of yards that's a
lot of yards in an AFC Championship game
and you know he made Dink and dunk but I
don't know let's take under 285. okay
um I think Burrow's gonna throw one to
Jamar Chase or t Higgins
break one
uh I think
I think Joe Burrough is going to throw a
touchdown to either uh T Higgins or
Jamar Chase for sure
okay okay so I can do it anytime for T
Higgins
no can't we just do a touchdown for Joe
burrow touchdown pass for Joe oh yeah
pass yeah so plus one passing pass what
plus one for Joe Burrow under 285 from
my homes and then
um what's Joe mixon's rushing yards
number
uh over under 60.
uh rushing receiving 25.
any other fun ones
great numbers they just picked there
yes you Smith Schuster uh over under 50
yards receiving
um Tyler Boyd over under 40 yards
receiving I'm gonna probably
um Travis Kelsey over under 85 yards
receiving is Travis Kelsey for a
touchdown
uh any anytime touchdown so yeah
receiving
I mean that's his guy in the red zone
every time
all right let's go with that then all
right so we'll go Travis Kelsey to
Travis Kelsey to catch one Joe bird
throw one and under Mahomes 285 passing
that could be a close game and not a
high scoring game
smash cut absolute blowout
my arms looks great
um
uh all right I wanted 74 yards in the
first half we don't even know which leg
was hurt
um all right let's uh
Let's uh wrap this up now so
both of us are taking the Eagles oof as
painfully as that is to say with with
this sitting next to me and that we're
gonna take the Eagles
laying
two and a half
and Bill is taking the Chiefs getting
one and I'm taking Cincinnati given one
and then we have our parlay for you guys
our Championship parlay okay Travis
Kelsey to catch a touchdown that's his
guy I like that Joe burrow to throw one
anytime in the game I like that and we
think Patrick Mahomes is going to go
under 285 passing yards
um I like that too so there you go and
uh guys as always just download the app
and you can play with us you put in the
anything better you could click on the
anything better parlay and bet with us
here's how you do it you go to bed MGM
you download the app use bonus code Burr
b-u-r-r it's very simple you put in as
much as 10 as little as 10 bucks and
they'll match up to a thousand even if
you lose all you got to do is make sure
you put in the bonus code our bonus code
for anything better is Burr b-u-r-r and
there you guys go uh bet responsibly and
like I said as little as 10 bucks up to
a thousand they're gonna match it
doesn't beat that get a stack he can't
beat it get a stack you know there you
go
um
enjoy Championship week what could I say
you know that was perfect get a stack
you wipe your nose you can't beat it
blow wait no
um
call your wife later get a stacked
you'll be fine
like one day a week I do blow 52 times a
year on Sunday
if we and then uh oh my God one more
week and then we'll be back with our
Super Bowl Edition next week but uh
actually we can wait Paul what's that
Pro Bowl this year buried it
to win big
you're gonna bet on that flag football
game that uh
there's always one that goes hard and
ends somebody's [__] career every
couple of years
no yeah it's it's yeah I do it you know
you know put a helmet on [__] hit
somebody
yeah
catcher's career the [__] All-Star
Game ran them over
oh
All-Star Game All-Star game that was
Pete Rose right what was the catcher's
name
nobody remembers for the Detroit Tigers
that's [__] horrible Andrew find out
who Pete Rose ran over just for his
family's sake if somebody's listening to
this the fact that you said nobody knows
is so horrible man that guy got
bulldozed
listen Paul sometimes life hurts
you know
sometimes you Pete Rose sometimes you're
the other guy just standing there with
waiting for the ball to come in dude
what Ray Fosse Ray Fosse I remember that
yeah
one
thing about sensation
they uh they just showed they just
showed a picture of Pete Rose like this
holding his first like gambling ticket
at like one at a sports book
and he's just like this because he bet
on like I think he bet on like one of
his teams and they just showed him there
and it was just such like a a prop it
was like
OJ holding a [__]
okay
guy that bet illegally on baseball to a
guy who [__] killed two people
no no I was thinking of like OJ holding
something that like as like a you know I
was gonna say knife probably an
off-color joke I'm sorry
um he's on the network he's on Chopped
oh
dude oh my wife the other day
she was watching one of those she
watches that food show where they have
the kids cooking and they fire the kids
because they can't [__] cook good
enough it's just a [__] horrible show
and she's watching it and there was this
kid on there he was such a [__]
little douche did you ever just see a
kid you just see the [__] corporate
CEO he's gonna be I don't want to
describe him because he's still a kid
and I don't want to [__] like
you know making like Gordon Ramsay
dude they're building another kitchen
for him to scream at people and you call
that a cupcake kind of how you cook it
he's not gonna be happy with it
[Laughter]
what do you say this what do you say to
your son if he's an Inspire aspiring
chef and he's gonna go on the Gordon
Ramsay show and it's all right Paul
listen you know you have the temper so
like when he starts yelling at you
because he's gonna yell at you just just
block it out just keep stirring that
just stirring that [__] thing in the
in the place if he screamed at my son or
daughter like that and I was there
I'd stick his dumb Irish head in boiling
water and be the end of the [__]
season
what
eat what he's English uh whatever
English
but that [__] dude somebody's got to
get him some lotion
his face looks like a [__] Rand
McNally map when I started
it's such an act to be that mad when
it's not good it's one thing to go like
this is he like gets like like he wants
to fight the person
yeah I mean it's a showman I will tell
you this when he when he was going
around in those [__] up restaurants
trying to fix them that show was my
favorite because the guy can cook his
[__] ass up I'm just breaking his
balls here that [__] thing when he
went in and he would go in they always
had some [__] piece of chicken that
had been there since last February and
he would be like oh go what was that
smell and he come in and you start like
[__] gagging yeah yeah like just
rancid [__] in that and it was
God bless I will tell you that dude like
you know if anything gets that guy into
heaven was was that show because he was
talking to some of the dumbest people I
it's like how do you how did you even
open a [__] restaurant they were so
[__] stupid
and uh
what was that called that wasn't called
Bar Rescue that was uh no
um
I know what it was though I know what it
was he would like find a failing
restaurant with like bad chefs and like
change the menu I forgot the name of it
it was like a restaurant version of Bar
Rescue but like you know
10 days of him leaving it just went back
to the same [__] it was
um kitchen nights oh kitchen nightmare
Kitchen Nightmares
um
uh all right guys well that's it I hope
you guys have a good championship week
hope your teams win hope you win some
money this has been the anything better
uh unfortunately second to last one ever
for this season uh oh that's tough to
say no more football no more but let's
all you guys out there
know what the [__] you're doing
all right guys this is the show uh enjoy
Championship weekend and we'll see you
next week
all right sorry I talked over you